no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
delay is very much hey everybody what's
going on
it's wednesday once again man this is
episode 299 i can't believe this we're
almost at 300 episodes
and well the 300 episode's just counting
the main episodes that doesn't even
count like all the [ __ ] movie reviews
that we've done and [ __ ]
all the other [ __ ] [ __ ] we did time
flies you know and movie reviews that i
did and book reviews that i did like on
my own there's all kind of could be more
than that yeah holy crap we just made so
much [ __ ] content yeah crazy crazy
crazy yeah i'm i'm drinking my damn
cuba sunrise man
what else is new
whatever happened to you you don't you
don't do your kukulkan anymore i don't
do that much anymore do i no you don't
that was like
that was like your signature i'm not
making you if you don't want to it's
just because i started to go for the
just more simple
yeah
i've been rushing it
and rushing it you got to take your time
with that yeah just kind of like boom
okay i'm going to do this
trying to simplify everything yeah
then we don't have to buy all those
different juices
that's true yeah that's true we can just
save orange juice and both drink it well
yeah because we can both drink that yeah
same thing because we both like that
instead of having to get mango and
pineapple right although you could just
get pineapple because pineapple uh juice
is good in vodka too and that's
perfectly fine
yeah i don't know that's [ __ ] but yeah
so hey everybody welcome to episode 299
we're gonna be talking about
bob happy little trees yeah ross bob
ross no relation to me
well not that you know no
i would heard about it
[Laughter]
talking about his happy little trees and
over here this is where waterfall
[Laughter]
we're lives to paint that waterfall look
at the little waterfall right here this
is that
and over here we're going to
we're going to put a little red house
because of course we need a red house
over here
just this happy little red house
nestled up in the back of the forest
next to all these happy happy trees
then you get your blade out
[Laughter]
please tell me somebody's done like a
horror bob ross crossover i mean
somebody must have um yeah i kind of
feel like it's really weird because
um i mean i grew up watching this guy
like from when i was probably wouldn't
when did he start on tv like 1983 1984.
so 70s but maybe no no no i mean he was
around before that but nobody really
knew who he was until like the early 80s
let's see who see him on pbs all the
time yeah and like so i used to watch
like not just his show but i watched
kind of like all the painting shows and
like some of the book shows too like uh
the book bird and stuff like that with
john robbins so i watched a lot of pbs
when i was you know 11 12 years old so i
used to see this all the time
and it's really funny until i kind of
like looked into
bob ross's background i didn't realize i
thought this was like a particularly he
was a particularly american phenomenon
but apparently not
uh he's actually they still
show his shows
all over the world and i'm talking about
in english well they're you know they
they dub it over
but into whatever language yeah so i
don't know if it's exactly the same
experience well i mean you know they'll
i guess they uh put closed captioning or
you know subtitles or whatever because
you do kind of need the voice that's
like part of the whole experience oh yes
but yeah they show it in they showed in
asia it's like in japan south korea it's
on the middle east like it's on an iran
a turkey and [ __ ] germany and there's
a uk it's on everywhere so i was just
kind of like well
yeah i mean the guy has reached pretty
much like global
saturation at this point
and
i never really thought of like doing a
show about him until a couple people
recommended it and i was like you know
what that might be pretty good idea
because i don't know if you guys know
but last year i don't remember what
month it was but netflix put out a
documentary
called
bob ross uh happy accidents betrayal and
greed and i actually i watched it when
it came out but i watched it again last
night
um and it's actually like really it's
just like don't be scared it's not one
of those things where because i saw that
title and i was like oh no are they
gonna tell me that like the lovely bob
ross is really like this horrible human
being no it's nothing like that he's a
he's a lovely human being apparently
everybody that know him said he was just
like he was on the show um you know not
you know he's not a perfect guy but
nobody is uh it was kind of more about
the shenanigans that happened like with
his business partners which we'll get
into and i'm going to say
at the beginning everything in here is
allegedly allegedly allegedly because i
don't want the [ __ ] to sue me
because apparently they're kind of too
happy
allegedly
allegedly
i'm just saying let's i'm just saying
some people are saying some people that
know them have said that they're kind of
too happy so you have to like really be
really careful like what you say about
them but other people have made videos
about it i watched one earlier today i
can't remember the guy's channel but i
just like subscribed to him and he made
like an hour long but he doesn't usually
do videos like this he did he does like
video games and [ __ ] like that but he's
like i love bob ross so much and he
looked younger he's probably like in his
30s or something he's like and i love
bob ross so much that i want to do like
a deep dive so he did like an hour hour
and 15 minute long video on it it's
really really funny um and you probably
find it like because i found it pretty
easy and there's also another
documentary about him that i think came
out in 2011
which is called bob ross the happy
painter which is a lot more kind of like
warm and cuddly type thing and it has
kind of like fans of his that are
talking and like you know that has like
clips from the show and everything like
that so that's also on youtube which i
watch for free or you can rent it on
amazon if you want to for 2.99 but i
watched it for free and like i said i
think it came out in 2011.
uh the one that the netflix one
is mostly based around his son steve
and some friends of his and talking
about
like i said the
all the conflicts that came into with
the
it's it you know it goes into his past
and stuff like that but it kind of goes
more into
what happened like when he was dying or
after he died and like what happened
with
bri like bob ross
incorporated like the company
so we'll get into that as well because
that's actually like pretty interesting
and
you know it's interesting too because
bob ross was like
it's kind of it's not impossible but
it's kind of like hard to find real deep
dive stuff like around about his
background because he was like a real
private person
and basically he just wanted to like
paint and teach other people how to
paint and he didn't really want
like i guess sometimes like when he got
real famous and he would be on talk
shows and [ __ ] like that and people
would ask him about kind of his personal
life and he always just kind of like
deflected this course he just thought it
wasn't relevant which
you know i i totally respect that he was
just like you know it's nobody's
business
i don't really think there was anything
like horrible going on behind the scenes
or anything like that but
you know there were a few things that
his son steve talked about on the
documentary which i'll get into but
it seems like
pretty much everybody that knew him uh
thought he was a great guy and said what
you see on the tv show is pretty much
exactly what he was like
um they said other than you know they
said he'd like cut up a lot more like
kind of uh you know do like joke around
more than he did on the show
but they're like other than that he was
just
like a lovely person and i didn't hear
anybody say anything
otherwise uh so all this stuff that was
sort of like negative in the netflix one
was not directed at him it was directed
at
the business partners so but like i said
we'll get into that
fourth chur down
bob ross burned a tree for everyone that
he paid
that's what i mean it's just kind of
like it would be like if somebody put
out because i kind of feel like he's
the reason i think that he still
resonates with a lot of people today and
it's not just like old people like
people our age it's younger people
i was read some [ __ ] about like some
people that because he kind of had a
resurgence like on twitch like back in
2015
and so a lot of like really younger
gamers like got into him because of you
know his voice and everything and
they're like oh my god this is like so
relaxing and
and everything and so he kind of had a
little bit of a resurgence and a lot of
people that got into him
didn't realize that he had died like a
really long time ago you know what i
mean because they would just like see
these videos of him and just assume that
he was like still around which i thought
was like really kind of yeah he died a
long time ago he died in 1995. he died
fairly young yeah i used to see him on
52. oh yeah it's young
used to see him uh on pbs all the time
uh i used to watch him used to watch
justin wilson cooking cajun yeah he was
great yeah and can't cook
remember that yeah martin yann i love
that yeah uh is that good what is that
dude doing now i don't know is he still
alive he's got to be like he's probably
going to be 80 right now there's there
was a bunch of them on there they used
to watch yeah i still love all that pbs
doctor who episodes
baker pbs used to be the [ __ ] man
yeah you can have that i was thinking
about getting that upgrade it's got it's
called brit box
it's an app yeah and i've heard of that
it's like 6.99
uh and it'll allow you to watch all uh
6.99 a month it'll allow you to watch
all the old doctor who episodes and then
i just cancel it afterwards i mean they
got a lot of good [ __ ] on there
otherwise yeah i don't know i don't know
what they have like as far as really old
yeah as far as really old stuff like i
don't know if they have like uh the
young ones of the comic strip or they
might because they had all those old
only fools and horses and stuff like
that like all that old [ __ ] that i used
to have those little doctor who's going
all the way back to the 60s
we'll see that might be worth watching
and they have like good [ __ ] on you
recently too you know what was that show
that i really got into it's like yeah
it's been a long time ago now it's
probably like 10 or 20 years ago but
was that what was like [ __ ] helen
marin like she played a detective or
some [ __ ] like that i can't remember
what it was
prime suspect prime suspect
something like that it was something
like that it was like a investigation
type like a mystery type thing
john smith says i love bob ross his show
was great for just going somewhere which
was tranquil with a nice person i think
that's kind of what everybody got out of
it because
you know i kind of feel like one a lot
of entertainment even back then was just
very like screechy and everything
everybody had to be like jumping up and
down and flash and [ __ ] in your face all
the time and so it was kind of nice just
to like chill out for half an hour just
with somebody that just was kind of like
soothing and like just like whispering
to you even if you didn't like paint or
didn't like want to paint it was still
like interesting like watching him
because he would just like kind of talk
very softly and he was really good at
what he did and he would paint the [ __ ]
in like 26 minutes or however long it
was
and you could just like watch it and it
was kind of like magically appearing on
the on the thing so i kind of feel like
there was that and there's also the
thing too
and i kind of feel like this is maybe
why
younger people resonate with them too
same with like mr rogers like why people
still talk about mr rogers uh you know
from the same era is that this he just
seems like a genuinely nice person and
you don't really get that like even
sometimes when you know you have a tv
show or a movie star or a celebrity or
whatever and like they seem like a nice
person but then you find out oh they're
a child molester or they kick puppies or
something like you find out something
really bad about them you're like ah
why isn't there anybody that's just like
a genuinely good person
that's famous but he actually was that
jasmine said did bob ross invent amsr
videos yeah basically they do call him
the godfather of it they didn't know
what that was back then yeah no such a
word but um
but basically now he is like the
acknowledged godfather if he was doing
it without really like realizing yeah
but so was so was uh um
mr rogers mr rogers was doing that too
with children yeah it was the same kind
of thing now some people have some eyes
that saw a thing you know because uh
there's a couple of amsr channels i'll
listen to to go to sleep little chinese
girl that pretends to be brushing your
hair
or [ __ ] yeah hair brushing is a big
asmr or another one that'll that'll put
you asleep is she's doing the chinese
[ __ ] rocks on your back yeah you know
what i mean and uh that one will put you
to sleep
and um
the uh they're saying that they think
that what that you know and it kind of
reminds me of being a kid
they say that it comes from um
animals uh
in what do you call them litters
that when they're up next to each other
nursing the mother or just sleeping that
they're getting that msr feeling and
that humans have inherited it
i didn't remember getting that as a
child
if you're around with your little
friends you're like one or two years old
and you get that kind of like
that amsr feeling if everybody was quiet
and that's that's what it's activating i
believe yeah because some people get
that like tingly feeling when they when
they have certain stimulants usually
auditory sometimes visual can do it too
but it's usually auditory yeah it's
instinct it's to keep you in the brood
next to the mother
that's what i think is going on maybe
that's why i like to put my head against
pookie's head like when she's when she's
purging like
and then i make the same noise that hair
keep the whole nest together
thank you zack what's zach saying one of
my favorite youtube videos is a guy
following along with one of bob's
tutorials in microsoft paint of all
things and the final result actually
looked great yeah
[Laughter]
well see the thing about him was that
the
the technique that he taught and we'll
get into the whole like where he got
that from and stuff like that because
that's like pretty interesting to you
but the technique that he thought was
that he taught was specifically for
people that i had always wanted to paint
but were scared to or didn't think
they'd be any good at it or anything
like that it's very easy to learn it's
pretty easy to master
and you can actually get kind of up and
running without too much because i mean
oil painting traditional oil painting is
very expensive which i know because my
ex-husband used to do it
so um all of the [ __ ] that you have to
buy it's just it's ridiculously
expensive if you want to paint like
because he painted it like a traditional
style like rembrandt so yeah it's really
expensive this one was like way cheaper
and way quicker and you could come up
with something that looked like pretty
[ __ ] decent it's not like you know
it's not gonna hang in the [ __ ]
louvre or anything like that but
you know you could hang up you could
like point to and go hey i made that and
that was kind of like what his main deal
was he didn't really care which you know
i'll get to this later but he didn't
really care that his stuff wasn't like
fine art or people like picked on his
like oh it's like [ __ ] that hangs in
hotels or whatever he's like that's not
what i'm trying to do i'm just trying to
teach people that they can create
something from nothing and they
shouldn't be afraid to
make something you know what i mean
that's and he's like that's all i really
care about doesn't have to be fine art
or nothing like that just something that
you made that you're proud of and he's
like as long as people do that then he's
happy you know what i mean and i'm gonna
go ahead and plug that msr channel
because i remember the name of it it was
called it's here on youtube it's called
ting ting amsr she's huge she's got
millions of followers millions
and she's [ __ ] great she's got a yeah
that's like a ton of videos it's a whole
sub genre yeah and uh there's she's got
a real strong chinese accent and there's
something about that accent that help
makes me zone out
maybe it's from you know partially
growing up in korea because
the korean accent when they're speaking
english kind of sounds like that too it
just sounds like you it sounds like the
voice of somebody you paid
you paid to provide some kind of service
like cut your hair or
something you know what i mean it
it's just because that's she's very like
professional
she's the librarian she's the stewardess
she has all the little videos
and it's just this voice
and you just [ __ ] zone out she'll be
in a costume too role playing that
you know taking your order on the
airplane
that one [ __ ] that one really put me
to sleep because does it have like the
air
in the back in the background yeah jet
turbines jet turbines put me to sleep
and yeah i don't like that that just
stresses me out because i hate flying i
love it
[Laughter]
makes me stressed
flying since i was a little kid and then
being in the coming up in 101st around
those jet turbines on those choppers and
[ __ ] sleeping on flight lines and
just doing all that [ __ ] and just
you know packing up [ __ ]
c5 galaxies and flying around and during
deployments there's just something
being all being around all your buddies
flying around all those jet engines and
everybody's sleeping in shifts
because it's just a massive [ __ ]
humanity [ __ ] packed up move and
everybody knows each other
you know
and i could fall asleep just [ __ ]
laying on my back on the middle [ __ ]
tarmac my head [ __ ] on the back of my
damn
butt pack on my lce and [ __ ] your
friends [ __ ] hey maybe get up here
smoke this you know give you a cigarette
wake you up to give you a cigarette you
know they just did all kinds of [ __ ]
just a funny world you guys if you
service guys know what i'm talking about
you you came up with that too but just
something real comforting
about jet turbines
fourth drawdown says bob ross bounty
hunter never made it to amber although i
kind of feel like probably somebody
should make that
yeah well uh isn't it just kind of like
wasn't there like a few years ago
um kind of an urban legend or like they
made a movie or something like that that
game show host what was his name chuck
barris was actually like a
secret agent or a cia assassin or
something
yeah but it was an urban legend like
before that
but yeah
um john smith says i listen to a podcast
about slasher movies hysteria continues
to help me sleep make of that what you
will honestly the closest i have to uh
to asmr is
dan bell because i like and i wish that
he would make more of his quiet time
videos well the thing is okay he makes
more he makes a lot of them but i think
they're mostly on his patreon which i am
on his patreon but i just i always
forget that i'm on his patreon and i
could go
listen to the quiet time videos but he
has like some that are on youtube that
are really long
and he specifically tries to
i mean he doesn't have an asmr channel
but so many people wrote to him and said
oh my god your voice is like so relaxing
and i fall asleep to it so he started
doing these quiet time videos with
you know other video footage that he
wasn't using for anything else
and the funny thing though is that
sometimes he'll try to do asmr so he'll
try to like whisper and stuff and then
like he'll crack himself up and like
like mess it up because he's not real
that's not really his thing he's talking
about damn damn yeah yeah he he's a
genius uh he has an editor he has like a
really really good voice yeah yeah his
voice and his editing is fantastic yeah
he's got one go go to dan bell and go
quiet time and yeah and he'll put you to
sleep like
i've said it many times on the show
before i i can't go to sleep in silence
i have to have because my my brain just
runs 20 i have hyper vigilance so my
brain just constantly runs and when it
gets
the quieter it gets the more my alert
status goes up
so i have to
the louder it is the more calm i am with
it's like a sign of safety for me so
it's just i don't see i'm the opposite
yeah i mean the thing about like my
brain runs all the time too but
um honestly if i'm watching something
that's noisy then i'm just like oh i
gotta pay attention to that but that'll
like keep me awake no i block it out
usually i block it out which [ __ ]
makes me relax
you know what i'm talking about yeah
because then because then that because
then if i hear something like if i'm
watching a movie or something like that
like i'll hear something on there i'm
like oh my god that reminds me of blah
blah blah and then i'll be off like
thinking of 40 bajillion other things
and then it's six in the morning but if
somebody's talking
to me and it's relaxing i'll fall asleep
yeah you know it's kind of like they're
on guard so i don't have to be awake
they're handling it i can trust them
it's that kind of yeah yeah
john smith said there's a funny youtube
video of very drunk irish people
attempting to follow a bob ross tutorial
with mixed results
i'm gonna have to watch that that sounds
[ __ ] hilarious uh oracle says it's a
painting uh you won't be ashamed of yeah
what i was talking about earlier uh
though he also deserved credit for
emphasizing that the whole point is to
have fun and enjoy it that's kind of
like what yeah and i really like that he
was
honestly and it wasn't just about
painting it was about any kind of
creative endeavor or just like about
life in general really he was just so
chill
and like the attitude that he had to
life
was just really
i mean it it just resonated with a lot
of people i guess because he was just
kind of like you know his whole thing
about we don't have mistakes we just
make it's just happy accidents you know
what i mean kind of like trying to make
something good out of you know like
overcoming obstacles and stuff like that
you know if you mess up the painting
it's okay you could just blur just make
it something else you know what i mean
so i kind of feel like this you know the
the sort of lessons that he taught can
it's not just painting it kind of goes
across life in general and i kind of
feel like a lot of people
uh related to him for that reason
because he was like just such a just
seemed like such a nice chill dude you
know everything yeah there's the maniac
saying that there's a rumor that he was
a sniper in vietnam that same rumor was
about um uh what's his name
john denver singer john denver yeah i
kind of feel like they say that about
every celebrity that seems too nice for
yay for this world anybody who's
mild-mannered that oh he was he was
something deadly in the army now it is
true that bob ross
was in the military for a long time
and i think i think glenn i think uh
and he did actually have to like yell at
people like all the time and he didn't
like it that's why he said after i get
out of the military he was in the
military for
15 20 years yeah i think john denver was
[ __ ] in the military for a while but
i i i vaguely remember checking that
myth and it turns out he wasn't a sniper
though he did something else
yeah bob ross wasn't a sniper no but
yeah neither was john david yeah
although i think john denver did do
something like oh he did it might have
been something with the air force i
don't remember what it was it was kind
of interesting but it wasn't it wasn't a
sniper
i worked with snipers in the first 327
recon
our fourth squad was a sniper
spotter squad
i was in first squad i was a recon scout
i carried the m203 or the [ __ ]
uh
each team you know was either it was an
m2 m203 gunner or an rto which carried
the radio i've done both
but there are snipers where our
overwatch
they were our protection
but if
everything was going by the book
so we talked about the snipers i think
of [ __ ] the snipers that i worked
with
you know they're nothing like bob ross
uh they're just
country boys you know kind of guys would
do deer hunting and stuff they're good
they're good dudes
you know but uh
kind of quiet
you know
um
that sniper course is tough
real tough
i think it's [ __ ] only half of them
make it and then they come back a lot of
it it's like [ __ ] that you wouldn't
think of is a lot of has to do with
[ __ ] passing camouflage
standards and uh just real meticulous
making ghillie suits
and then
the other half of it is all that
marksmanship stuff and they gotta like
hit man size targets out to i think
[ __ ] a thousand meters or 1100 meters
i don't remember what it was most of
it's at 900 but some of those shots are
really long and they got to do
or they don't make it but there's like
some course that they had to go through
and they couldn't
be spotted when they went through it and
how they judged whether or not you could
have been seen it was kind of iffy back
in the 90s and
luck had a lot to do with all those
courses man
you know
[ __ ] i didn't make it through ranger
school because of luck
which is during during the pre-ranger
trials
just coming up yeah i had to swim down
12 feet into swimming pool
full gear with my rifle and the helmet
and everything and get a damn rucksack
which is a backpack for you civilians
and bring it up off the bottom of the
pool and [ __ ] come all the way up
and you had to do it within a certain
amount of time limit and i dropped the
rifle on the on the way up and there's
not enough time to go down and get it
so that's it you get pulled up that was
the last no-go there was two other ones
there's three no goes during that pre
pre-rip [ __ ]
trial thing that we did i forgot what it
was called
but uh a lot of is just luck
you know bad luck which that's part of
the military motif man
dice and cards and
you're gambling with your life so you
know you got to have good luck
john smith said my mother said i was a
happy accident
yeah i'm sure a lot of people mom said
that um
dj maniac says the thing is bob ross
studied under wilhelm alexander yeah
we'll get into that uh
shortly and he was the complete opposite
of ross in terms of tone yeah i remember
because i used to watch that guy too uh
wilhelm alexander would scream about
everything through the entire lesson if
you learn to paint watching a show it
was completely incidental yeah that dude
he was um he wasn't angry he was just
like really uh
boisterous he was very boisterous and um
you know he had a really really thick
german accent and you know no offense to
like german speakers but german at least
two english-speaking ears does sound
like very harsh so he did come across as
like soundy like
like poking at the canvas and [ __ ] like
that so yeah so i kind of feel like
there was i don't know if bob ross i
mean because i kind of feel like
you know his
natural sort of personality came through
but i do think there was like a
deliberate
um
you know kind of a deliberate decision
to go the opposite way to what bill
alexander was doing because bill
alexander was like kind of real hyper
um
and i think bob ross or at least like
his business partners were kind of like
you know
most of the people watching this show
are probably women and they probably
don't want some dude like shouting at
them constantly like while they're
trying to learn to paint so maybe you
should just like chill the [ __ ] out a
little bit um although you know who's to
say because bill alexander was like
really really successful too
um
yeah and we'll get into that too because
i kind of feel like a lot of stuff that
people
this is a spoiler alert but a lot of
stuff that people attribute to bob ross
like a lot of his catchphrases um and
stuff like that um actually came from
bill alexander like bill alexander said
them first he said happy little clouds
and happy little trees and [ __ ] like
that he said all that it's just that
um you know he taught bob ross and bob
ross got more famous than him
after and you know they were friends for
a while but then bill got a little
pissed off about it later lars is asking
how much is an original bob ross
painting well see that's the thing
there's probably a lot of them out there
no there is i mean there are because he
painted like
he estimated something like 20 000
paintings i believe it um but the thing
about it is that his business partners
the kowalski's which we'll get into
um
they don't sell them they don't display
them they basically have them in box
like marked boxes
like in their warehouse why would they
do that i'm not real i'm not entirely
sure why um
they have the right to sell them if they
want to
i guess they do okay but um
i don't they just don't for whatever
reason
now
so they have them but the weird thing
about it is that
i don't know they kind of went into this
on the netflix documentary there was
this one guy on there who they
interviewed who was a german fella
and he started working for
bob ross incorporated either right
before bob ross died or shortly
afterward and at that point they were
trying to expand into more like global
markets right so they wanted to
kind of establish
um a presence like in germany so this
guy was like working there and he said
that he went into their warehouse there
and that there were paintings that
looked like bob ross paintings because
like i said he taught you know he taught
people to paint that way so you could
paint something that looked like a bob
ross painting and then he said i saw
somebody like signing his signature like
onto the paintings it obviously wasn't
bob ross because he had died so he's
like at that point he got a little
disillusioned with the whole thing
so
the weird thing too is and i'm not sure
if this is true allegedly what they said
on the netflix documentary was that
annette kowalski who was one of whose
business partner is the only person
that's allowed to authenticate a real
bob ross painting
um and there's kind of like i don't know
it's very
sketchy allegedly the whole situation
it's just very strange they're very very
protective and like i said that's why
i'm being really careful what i'm saying
because they're really protective of
their
brand
um
and they have been known to sue people
that
you know kind of take advantage of the
bob ross brand in any way
possible or like say magic like i know
that like they did the netflix
documentary and apparent apparently that
was fine they asked them
you know the docu documentary filmmakers
like asked the kowalski's to participate
but they
didn't want to
and
honestly the netflix documentary
is pretty
uh scathing about them
um you know all the people like you know
bob ross's son and like a lot of the
people that knew him and like came up
with him and stuff and a lot of them
really really didn't like the kowalski
or didn't like what they did to his
image like after he died
so we'll get into that uh as well but
yeah it's like actually a pretty
interesting so it's a good documentary
on netflix and like i said it's
interesting to watch
that one which as i said is a more
negative portrayal not bob ross
obviously because he's a great guy but
of the whole business situation around
you know the the corporation and then
watching the one from 2011 the happy
painter which is a much more bright
which the kowalski's did participate in
because they're both interviewed on
there and i watched that earlier today
and uh you know so that one is a lot
more sunny
and positive because they were involved
and they apparently don't allow anyone
to like say anything
bad about it ever because they don't
want any like besmirching of the
of the brand like i said
so
there's that
let me see uh
oh wait
straw dogs was asking me something about
um tabasco sauce
um
he said that
i wanted to know if i put tabasco sauce
in my eyes to stay away during stay
awake during regular school
i think i think you misunderstood me i
never got to ranger school
i was in the first three two seven
recounts to recap was a recall platoon
i was in there for a [ __ ] man
eight nine months i think it was around
that time and then um a
they sent me and five other guys
to a division level like a pre-rip type
school which is a big testing if you
made it through that
little [ __ ] thing it was like 10 days
long if you made it through that it was
kind of like eib course really if you
know what i eib course is a bunch of
these little tasks
if you made it through that they would
send you to raider school
me and those other like four or five
guys that they sent we all [ __ ]
boloed from that little [ __ ] test and
it was mostly a combination of things
like
swim test
errors and call for fire and encode
decode that kind of stupid [ __ ] it's
like eib
we went back to the platoon after that
after all that [ __ ] went down they kind
of held that against us
and with probably six months later they
sent all of us out of the damn platoon
and sent us to the line
to regular line companies but by the
time that that happened we didn't really
care
because we only had like [ __ ] six
seven eight months left
on on our enlistments so we didn't care
they were just
you gotta understand the military's it's
like a beauty contest between pretty
girls and everybody in that
motherfucker's pretty so it's a bunch of
mean girls and you got to be on top of
your game 24 7 if you're going to be in
those badass units
and me and the mother guys were i guess
we were our
our [ __ ] uh
fresh date was going out of date and
they were going to replace us with new
ones that they thought might make it
through ranger school because they had
it in their mind that everybody in that
goddamn platoon was going to have a
ranger tab
and it was just because of the damn new
platoon leader and a platoon sergeant
that was in there trying to make a name
for themselves which i didn't really
want to go to ranger school anyway man
because i knew exactly what that
entailed it's like asking yeah send me
to a concentration camp because every
time those guys came back from [ __ ]
range of school they were skinny and
emaciated and [ __ ] i knew exactly
what that course was about the [ __ ]
hell hell on earth back in the 90s
terrible
ultimate nut check and you didn't learn
anything it was just
a nut check to see if you could [ __ ]
do it and most dudes couldn't the
attrition rate was [ __ ] terrible
you didn't you couldn't make it so i was
already kind of demoralized i knew
that i couldn't make it through 90s
ranger school i see what they're doing
now i've had to be i'd sail right
through that [ __ ] still hard but
keep me on steroids and get right
through [ __ ] range of school
modern rangers go old right to school no
you're not enough not enough food not
enough sleep
flash of fred says uh speaking of pbs
there was a show i used to watch called
ghost writer i remember that that
involved these youngsters who helped
solve crimes with the help of this
magical being yeah i remember that show
i don't remember like a great deal about
it but yeah i remember watching some of
those as well so yeah a couple other
people remember that thank you zach
if you keep up with shows on artists i
bet a show on thomas kincaid would be a
hell of a ride i bet it would too
i'm kind of curious about that dude
because
it's not every artist and even [ __ ]
bob ross
doesn't have mall stores that are
completely devoted to his artwork yeah
so there's got to be a story there
i'm just and i never really thought
about it until you said something but
now i'm like yeah now i'm kind of
intrigued like how does that happen you
know what i mean holy [ __ ]
uh harold m i wanted to be a painter but
they gave me the brush off oh god the
dad jokes
[Laughter]
yeah another pbs famous show's
masterpiece theater that had the host
sitting at sitting his lounge chair
telling stories yeah i remember that one
and remember like pbs mystery that had
like the edward gory animation at the
beginning i remember that one too
so yeah that's pretty cool i'm i do you
guys remember i don't know how
widespread this was because i know that
like some pbs stations
um you know some of the [ __ ] was
national but some of it was regional
so
there used to be a show and i think it
was called the book bird or there was
one called cover to cover but it was the
same guy that hosted it and his name was
john robbins and what he would do
was that he would pick like a book every
show and it was usually like a why a
novel like it's usually like a newberry
medal winner like you know the westing
game or the headless cupid or
something like that
and
he would like read they would read
uh excerpts from it and he would like
draw scenes from it like usually with
it wasn't charcoal but it was like uh
like colored pencil or chalk or
something like that and man i used to
think that was like really mesmerizing
too and it's it's pisses me off because
i feel like i tell people about it i
don't think anybody remembered it but me
but i actually like found a really lot
of my favorite childhood books from
watching that show
and i looked on youtube and there's a
couple episodes on there i think there's
like three or four episodes on there but
that's it and i remember seeing a bunch
more than that because i can remember
like a lot of the books that he covered
because i remember his drawings
but
i kind of feel i don't know maybe that
was more regional
i mean the bob ross show that was like
everywhere like i said they
they started out it started out regional
i think in the midwest but then like it
went national and then it started going
international because it just really
started taking off
so but i but i know that some pbs shows
were more regional because they had
pbs they each had their own thing so
it's like if they would decide
the regions they would decide like what
shows they wanted and [ __ ] like that so
you know i'm not entirely sure how it
works because i don't work in tv but
you know
uh let's see okay
murder hornet says me and tom are in the
army around the same time
we might have crossed paths at some
point he was at fort campbell i was in
nashville yeah yeah see there you go
maybe so it's hard hard to say
so
let me uh do a couple of these shout
outs which we haven't had any of these
for a while but i got a really nice
message the other day
from a woman named uh she said please
call her kty
and she sent me a paypal donation oh
great and uh she said hi jenny hi tom i
love you guys we love you too
i first found out about you when jenny
was on where did the road go oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah i've been on there for
you that's a great show they've been in
a long time yeah we haven't we used to
go on there
yeah
and i've been listening to you guys ever
since i even listened to the previous
episodes it's so fun to watch your show
because jenny reminds me of how i think
sometimes
yes
that's pro that's pretty scary
and tom makes me laugh all the time i
love the i love the vibrato he puts in
his preacher voice oh you haven't done
that in a while the preacher voice
anyway i have done a preacher in a while
yeah yeah you haven't but i remember how
you did that
so i'm the clown of the show i'm the
comedic relief but it's not it's not a
joke man it's [ __ ] real it is real
it's just my version of it
go ahead yes he is like the clown
version of life
the jester first it's real
the dudes know what i'm talking about
from women's point of view man's always
going to look like a joke you know what
i mean we're [ __ ] no man we're in
this the case we're in a different world
we know that's not the case okay go
ahead
i mean a lot of stuff it's not so much
that stuff that you all do is funny it's
like stuff that y'all do is just like
not all of it but just some of that
uh so she says i'm donating to you
through paypal because i can't become a
patron at this time getting settled into
my new job that's fair enough thank you
very much i teach a mythology course i'm
also getting that's cool yeah i'm a myth
assistant i mean i love all that kind of
yeah uh as you probably know if you uh
watch the show i'm also getting my
certificate in social studies and in
order to get it this is really cool i
had to write a paper i called it red
witchcraft institutional persecution of
the religious and ideological
non-conformism yeah it covers the salem
witch trials uh sacrament vanzanty trial
alger his trial and the mcmartin
preschool trial which we talked about on
our satanic panic show in order to get
some of the information for the last
section part of my research was
listening to you guys so the short of it
is that you have been referenced in a
university paper oh my god i feel like
hopefully i didn't [ __ ] anything up on
that show i might have been kind of
fixed i'm i love i love mythology
i consider myself to be a christian
mythicist uh
i'll [ __ ] listen to like myth vision
podcasts we've had dr price on the show
um
i'm a cultural christian
but but a mythicist i don't believe any
of that stuff happened i believe it's
mythology uh i see things kind of like
the joseph campbell way of seeing things
i kind of graduated into more of
blending east and west together and um i
think what i may be is a part of a dead
religion
known as the manikins
the manikins were
east and west combined
and uh kind of like the prototype that
campbell and lucas used
to uh come up with the idea of the jedi
the jedi and the sith that's
manichaeanism
uh so i'm
gonna recommend go check out check out
the mannequins and uh
myth vision podcast did a couple shows
on on manichaeanism and
i think you might like that that's just
my recommendation
and then she says i hope this doesn't
sound terrible or that i've insulted you
in any way but if you would like to read
it i can send you a copy i would
actually love to read it uh so please
send me that i i would really like to
read it please let me know what decision
you make yes please send me a copy i
really want to read i hope the rest of
your week as well i'm actually
presenting the paper on friday so wish
me luck good luck with that uh i'm sure
it's awesome love you guys you always
make me smile sincerely ktype oh thank
you so much that is like so so sweet
that is so [ __ ] awesome
uh lars alright said it's a bit like the
situation with warhol yeah some people
have been authorized to make a wooden
box or something and then it's genuine
yeah i kind of feel like it's the same
which is kind of sad i mean i don't know
if bob ross
i don't know like i said we'll get into
this later
um because they talked about this in the
netflix documentary i don't know if bob
ross necessarily would have minded
um the sort of
i don't know the the sort of what would
you call it the factorization the
the automation or whatever like of
paintings being like kicked out that
were like not painted by him that were
sort of so i don't know but they're not
selling the paintings necessarily they
are selling like a [ __ ] ton of other
stuff
um
but i don't know if he'd be mad
he seemed like he you know toward the
end when he was dying he really didn't
like the idea of like selling his like
signing away his name to them
because he had like his own ideas but it
didn't work out apparently the way he
wanted
but
i don't know he wasn't really hung up
about
oh this is like a f the finest piece of
art and i have to sell it for all this
money and [ __ ] like that he wasn't
really
concerned about that so i don't know
i'm not entirely sure like how he would
react to what happened maybe he would
just be happy that his images
proliferated but i don't know we'll get
into that i didn't know the guys so i'm
not really saying john smith said in the
sh in the uk we had jack nory a kids
show in which a celebrity would read a
book over the course of a week see that
sounds cool i would have watched that
tom baker reading the iron man was
amazing as was rick male rick male oh my
god i love him
he died didn't he passed away a few
years ago uh tom baker does iron man
well not yeah or he reads the book iron
man yeah he said man that sounds good
that's what i mean well see we could
probably look on uh youtube because i
don't think i've ever i've heard of it
but i don't think i've ever seen that
huge fan of tom baker had a man crush on
tom bicker since i was a little boy
watching him as [ __ ]
doctor who back in the 70s
i talked about it earlier in the show
i'm thinking about i'm going to get brit
box just so i can watch all the old
doctor who episodes i i haven't seen
every one of them
that had tom baker in it well if you get
it if you get it let me poke through
there and see if there's a good [ __ ] i
want it's only 6.99
oh well [ __ ] should i get it that's only
a buck more than shutter oh yeah okay
i'll get it
i mean stuff i mean shutter i pay for
that like once a year so that's like
super cheap it's like 59 for a year
that's right pay for it it's probably
cheaper if you pay for it like a year at
once yeah you know what i'm saying they
most of them are well look at
i don't know if i'll keep it a year but
uh it seems to be easy to cancel but
i've seen commercials for it and it
looks like it has good [ __ ] on there it
has every one of the classic doctor
who's going back to the 60s all
throughout the 80s i mean i think some
of that stuff from the 80s i'd probably
like to see also that'd probably be
worth getting and like i said i'm i'm
really really into like a lot of the
british stuff from the 80s and they
probably have all that comedy on there
like young ones and [ __ ] the goodies
and [ __ ] benny hill and [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is hilarious
i used to watch benny hill when i was a
kid it's not funny anymore but it used
to be yeah when you're a kid it was
funny young ones is totally still funny
though i would be young [ __ ] watching
benny hill and they're busting out the
women
i was going oh man i wish i was old
enough to get that
well yeah that was kind of like well you
know the brits the brits understood well
they love they love boobs boobs it's a
very boob-centric yeah culture
particularly it was back then i don't
know about nowadays but he's probably
cleaned it up now they're like oh no we
can't have that i don't know do you guys
still have page three girls is that
still a thing i know nobody buys like
print newspapers anymore but
if they did i mean i was of the opinion
i haven't been to the uk since 2009 so i
don't and they still had page three
girls then so i don't know evidently
even back in the late 80s they were
cracking down on um
[ __ ] benny hill and accusing him of
being some kind of sexist pig and
evidently no he wasn't he lived by
himself a very meager light uh income
really he didn't make but he would have
could be considered basically poor by
american standards they weren't paying
that [ __ ] they showed his apartment he
was living in that his little house and
he's on television because an american
television performer is a [ __ ]
millionaire well depends because when
you're talking about bob ross he didn't
get paid for that tv show he did that
for free yeah but that was state that
was state time yeah that was pbs he his
money came from teaching classes in
person and selling like branded paints
and kits and [ __ ] like that that's where
all his money had benny hill been
american and that was that show was
happening in the united states he'd have
been living in beverly hills
but anyway they say he was like sweetest
guy ever he wasn't some misogynist or
sexist pig he just knew what soul he
knew it sold and he was he just thought
it was good-hearted you know funny stuff
i think it was put the strippers on
there you know what i mean let them
[ __ ] literally let them jiggle let
them make their money
startup 78 said i remember when bob ross
started doing those mtv ads in the early
90s yeah i remember that too
yeah mtv it's all a bunch of happy
little trees or it's all just fluffy
white clouds or something like that yeah
it um
thinking that dude's still alive he was
an icon even back then and i kind of
feel like that really helped because
i mean that was the 90s that was when i
mean because he died in 1995 but so that
was like a year or two when did he do
those ads like maybe a couple years
before that and i kind of feel like that
that slotted right in because that's
like right when i right around when i
was like 20 21 years old and that
slotted right in with the whole gen x
like we're being ironic thing so we're
like getting all into like the ironic
it's you know people these kids nowadays
they think they invented like retro like
all this retro vintage irony and all
that other stuff no we were doing that
like way back then and yeah that's why
they had bob ross doing the [ __ ] but
john smith said page three ended some
years ago oh okay benny hill was taken
off air and died alone shortly after he
seemed to earn to earn money but really
didn't care how much he lived
and then somebody said uh er
air health said that hill died in his
bathrobe watching television that's
they said he was a very um
friendly
simple kind of guy who was um
amazed that he was being attacked over
that show that he he uh he was amazed by
it and kind of had his feelings hurt
because
he didn't take any that seriously he was
just putting on a show and trying to
entertain people which you know i feel
you i feel you benny i feel you i didn't
take it seriously it wasn't
anything [ __ ] against [ __ ]
civilization or anything it was just
putting on a [ __ ] show it was
hilarious
slapping that little guy on the top of
his head and [ __ ] it's just funny you
know i haven't seen it a long time yeah
it was just funny
grampa's hammer who would you rather
party with benny hill or benny hinn
that's a pretty easy question to answer
nobody wants to party with benny in
any minute he might come along and be
like you're healed and like smack you in
the head and knock you over
i have the idea that benny hill wasn't
amazingly funny if you were hanging out
with him he was just making a show
well a lot of comedians yeah are kind of
like depressed yeah that's yeah which
you know i don't want to generalize too
much but a lot of them are um the reason
they become comedians is because it's a
defense mechanism like they're kind of
trying to cover up because they want to
make other people happy they want to
make other people laugh he was just a
middle-aged guy who probably couldn't
get laid and was just amazed by women
and humor and comedy
he kind of represented just the average
guy
sitting at home
you know
which i think was a large part of
probably why that show worked of course
yeah of course
you looked at the guy he just didn't
look like he didn't even look like
anybody famous you know
although you can kind of say that about
a lot of british stars i guess so yeah
well they're not i mean the british
probably it's less so nowadays i kind of
feel like but back in the old days they
used to think it was very funny that
like everybody on american tv or
american movies had to look completely
perfect yeah you had to be beautiful
like nobody like whereas they were more
open to just having people that looked
like regular people like in their movies
and tv shows that didn't come to the
united states until the 90s yeah that
was that was like later like yeah in
ours everybody had to be even if you
were just like a you know a [ __ ]
hooker if you even if you're a hooker
you had to look like [ __ ] julia
roberts
if your job was you couldn't look like a
real ugly ass witch you were a 10 and
then they made you ugly yeah they
couldn't even put like an actual
or even like a plain person in a role
it's like we have to have this hot
person and we'll make
we'll put glasses on her yeah glasses
then that's and pull all her hair back
into a ponytail
boom ugly
[Laughter]
and we'll put her in a baggy sweatshirt
no actor actress was synonymous
synonymous with beautiful
um hollywood was synonymous for
beautiful in american culture just
that's the way it was going all the way
back to the 20s
dj maniac says comedian here can confirm
yeah it's like i'm sure not all of them
are like that but
um a lot of commit a lot of the best
comedians
are if you met them in person are
actually like
wrestling with depression and like other
issues
the reason they become comedians is like
i said they're
it's a defense mechanism they're trying
to like
make other people laugh make other
people happy it's a way to get accepted
you drink up yeah so we should maybe get
into this huh yeah oh one more thing i
wanted to mention uh tammy sent me a
message about this and i was gonna
mention it on one of the movie reviews
because
what oh wait do you need to hear this no
okay because um because i heard about it
like right before we did one of the
movie reviews but
you guys know i'm a big fan of nick cave
and his son
jethro
uh died now
if you guys didn't know just a few years
ago
his son arthur also died um arthur died
when he was 15. he was actually like on
lsd in brighton in england where they
lived and he accidentally fell off a
cliff and died
his twin brother earl is still alive
but
uh jethro
he went by jethro cave but his actual
birth name was jethro lazenby i think he
was actually um 31 i believe and he had
been working like as a model and he was
an actor and stuff like that they're not
saying how he died um he had been
diagnosed with schizophrenia and a few
years ago he had kind of gotten in
trouble for
uh domestic abuse like spousal abuse um
or he's like beating up on his
girlfriend and i think he'd also like
beat up on his mom uh a few times too so
he was uh having some issues
but um nick actually did confirm that uh
that his son died like a little while
ago but i don't know what the cause of
death was so yeah that's like pretty
shitty
especially just because his teenage son
died not too long ago in a horrible
horrible accident so yeah i just thought
i would mention that because i'm a big
fan of his um yeah the aristocrat sketch
yeah
they have nick cage dolls probably i'm
somebody makes one
uh let's see they're talking about yeah
alley g
yeah that's right i haven't seen too
much of it but
if you need to see the difference
between uk and us comedy check out the
us pilot of red dwarf
oh i should yeah
i mean i i like some american comedy but
i'm not a real big fan of
comedy films like in general or comedy
tv shows like there's some american
comedies i like like i really liked i'm
trying to think i don't really watch a
lot of um
funny like movies or shows or anything
but one that i remember really liking
that was american was arrested
development i thought that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] hysterical somebody used to tape
it for me
like back in the old days or somebody
used to like burn it to dvd and i used
to watch it so yeah so i thought that
was like super funny but
growing up i don't know i always just
british humor was like funnier to me i
don't know why
um
i can't really put my finger on it
exactly i do a lot of american comedy i
feel like is trying too hard maybe
that's what it is
and i think the reason that i thought
arrested development was so funny was
because it was
more like situationally funny and like a
little bit absurdist and it was a lot
drier where i kind of felt like i don't
know i feel like a lot of american
comedy is just kind of like screaming in
your face like it's funny
and i just can't like and that's a
generalization it's not all like that
but i don't know i feel like a lot of it
is like that like it's trying too hard
and i don't i don't like try hard kind
of stuff just be funny or don't you know
what i'm saying just like if you have to
try then to just knock it off
so there is a nicholas cage doll
that's based on his character from mandy
it's more of an action figure that oh my
god i think i might need to get my my
hands on that is it anatomically correct
[Laughter]
well that's the big question isn't it
uh john smith in the us red dwarf they
made the black character white huh
that's yeah figures well you know
that's gonna happen that's gonna happen
all right
okay so how long has it been okay so
we're an hour in so we should we have
been talking about bob ross off and on
but i kind of want to get to the show
because i this is one of those topics
that i thought this would be an
interesting show because
when i first watched the netflix
documentary
i'm like because i had watched bob ross
when i was you know when i was a kid i
used to watch it on public television he
was like fascinating
but i never really gave much thought to
what was going on behind the scenes and
he wasn't the only painting show that i
watched i watched bill alexander i used
to watch the other the jenkins they did
the flowers and [ __ ] there was like
other painters on there that i watched i
watched the cooking shows like you said
you know i watched the the book guy so i
watched a lot of that growing up
and but i never really thought about it
like more than that but when i was like
scrolling through netflix like last year
in that netflix documentary you know the
the bob ross like betrayal and greed one
and i was just kind of like man that's i
wonder if that's really interesting so i
started watching i'm like wow that was
like actually a really interesting
documentary and but i didn't think about
doing a show about it until a couple of
people like recommended it and i was
like yeah that probably would make a
pretty cool show because there's i don't
know
it's one of those things that you don't
that you maybe don't initially think
would be interesting but like then the
more you look into it like the more
interesting it gets maybe that's true of
everything i'm not harassing asking
about [ __ ] nick cage dolls you're
talking about nick cage dolls well no i
was talking about nick cave and then
somebody's brought up like nicolas cage
and then uh and then he said there was
one
well there's an action figure based on
his mandy character okay
so there is the mandy character yeah
okay cool is he all bloody like does he
have a chainsaw is he all bloody yeah
that you know what oh
they should have him like where he was
that scene where he's like in the
bathroom where he's just like in that
shirt and his tighty whities yeah and
he's just locked back up and he's like
screaming gotta see that movie again i
have that don't i
i'm pretty sure you do i'm going to
check i bought him like for christmas or
his birthday or something like that a
couple years ago i bought him a really
nice like silk poster
from that of now i'm going to see if i
have that moving
i thought we had it well i know we have
color out of space yeah
but it's pretty good some people didn't
like it but i liked it i didn't like it
as much as mandy no man he was better
but it's it was still pretty good it's
still one of the best lovecraft movies
and it's hard to get a lovecraft movie
right and the one where he's in there
fighting the [ __ ] animatronic robots
chuck e cheese willie's wondering
wonderland's good too i'm going to get
that one
nick cage
what's his name nick nicholas cage
nicholas cage
he either makes a [ __ ] fantastic
movie or it's just a piece of [ __ ]
there's really nothing really in between
well isn't he in a movie that's at the
theater right now called like the
unbearable what is it called the
unbearable weight of massive talent or
something like that yeah maybe isn't he
in that
oh the fire starter remake starts
this week okay we gotta see that too and
then that movie men starts next week
okay i looked up when the new david
cronenberg was coming out but i don't
know because it said june 2022 but
that's when it's premiering at the
cannes film festival which obviously i
can't fly to france i mean jenny had
many minions me and jenny have the
[ __ ] stubs planned on [ __ ] amazing
amc stuff yeah so we get to see three
movies a week for free
yeah for 20 bucks it's like 20 something
bucks a month and we wouldn't even use
them all
well and especially
we've been using it less lately because
it's farther from the farts because we
moved farther away we moved farther away
and yet that movie theater is still the
closest one like the one by our old
house yeah so now it's like a whole day
ordeal like the last one we went and saw
the north man but before that what was
the last one we went and saw before that
i don't even remember
y'all need to see the north man
yeah that's as good as conan one i mean
it's up there man [ __ ] i love that movie
i gotta see it again i want to buy it
jason says i live in australia and we
get mash reruns every year best satire
comedy yeah mash was actually pretty
[ __ ] funny
john smith just looked up benny hill's
estimated net worth by the time of his
death was in today's money around 13
million pounds damn he was that's that's
[ __ ] 26 million dollars
his [ __ ] look he looked he was living
like he was broke
maybe he was just one of those people he
was one of those guys that just lived
frugal i guess not really frugal he just
lived he lived regularly
yeah some people don't really even if
they have a lot of money because i kind
of feel like bob ross was that type of
dude he was just like a humble kind of
dude yeah like even though
like he probably had money like they had
okay money he just never really felt in
it now he did have like a sweet corvette
though because they said he was real he
really liked to like drive real fast and
like take people for rides and go check
this out like he used to like to do that
but
from what i could determine like he
didn't have no [ __ ] mansion or
nothing like that you know he just kind
of lived right if you have 26 million
dollars in the united states [ __ ] you
live in a gigantic mansion
there's lots of those
they got used ones that they can't even
sell well see i don't know if i would do
that though because i don't i mean
as much as i would like to live like in
a creepy haunted castle that would be
awesome i don't want like a big [ __ ]
giant one because
i don't want to clean it one and two i
feel bad having to hire other people to
clean it i've looked into it because you
know it just seems like an expense i
don't need
i've looked into it because of the
[ __ ] urban exploration the urbex
videos uh on youtube i've looked into
the mansion scene
and um they say people that live in them
end up living in only like
a small apartment
inside the mail well yeah of course the
rest of the time they don't even go in
there
because why would you i mean in your
day-to-day life you really only need a
couple of rooms yeah your sleeping room
your tv watching room and evidently the
people that buy
them for the first time after a few
years
don't like them
they say it's kind of like living at a
hotel
and to run one properly you need an
entire staff so it's like a business
that's what i'm saying it's just it's a
headache yeah why would you what they
end up doing a lot of times is having an
area cleaned up and then just shut off
that they don't even go there
and if they have a party or something
they'll turn power on and air
conditioning on to that side of the wing
and
they'll revive it
for an event but
in their normal everyday life that uh
they're evidently not practical at all
even
i'm calling it a mansion i'm it's really
almost kind of like a mick mansion most
of them
we have them around here they're huge
houses
but for
usually it's a family of two they don't
even have children
the guys that own them it's a dude and
his girlfriend
he's a lot of times he's not even
married to him
he's some guy that struck it rich
in some kind of a [ __ ] business
and he's a middle-aged
overweight dude who's bald
and he's got this [ __ ] gigantic house
it's not really doing anything for him
in terms of his
date ability or anything
you know what i mean it's just
he's a random dude
in this thing
it's another i mean we live in a big
house but it's not a mansion
and the thing about it is they're in the
big house we don't use all that's what i
mean even in this house i really don't
have a clue like what to do with some of
the space yeah because i'm like what do
i don't need that though one room is
just my [ __ ]
gym
and i i gotta get in there and paint it
and [ __ ] paint the walls it doesn't
have curtains or not doesn't even it has
it has blinds on it but it doesn't and
there's really just that [ __ ] gem in
there that's all it doesn't look good i
want it's just empty car and
this is really the only room that's
super decorated yeah
because i got it because i knew that
this was going to be on camera so i came
in here like first thing and painted it
and put [ __ ] up this house is a studio
this room is a studio basically right
but it's like we have that big long like
living room [ __ ] over there it's like
there's nothing in there there's two
living rooms basically and [ __ ]
there's nothing really the upstairs one
it's like yeah the fridge is we have a
fridge and an ice maker in there we have
like a couple chairs and the cat tree
and that's it but the rest of it's just
blank
and an american mansion is four of these
so
ah yeah i really do that's what i mean i
don't i can't imagine that i would ever
need to live anything bigger than this
because like i said i can't max this out
i can't even think of like what to do
with most of the space in this place we
don't get enough super chats to [ __ ]
furnish this place
[Laughter]
it'll come but although like i said i
don't really want to furnish it because
i don't like the color i got to [ __ ]
paint it yeah first so well that's what
i mean i came in here
before we moved in and painted this [ __ ]
before i moved all the furniture in
because i said i don't want to move
furniture because i [ __ ] hate doing
it right so i came in and painted this
and i painted the bathroom and then i
got furniture and like moved it in here
but the thing about it is that i mean
honestly i spend
how many hours a day in this room
oh almost most of the day pretty much
all day like i come in here
at 7 30 8 in the morning yeah
and i'm in here until like 7 8 at night
well there's nowhere else really to go
in here yet that's what i mean yeah and
it's just kind of like i have a little
couch over there like if i could lay on
this living room i want to put a bar in
it if i can hook up another sink on the
other side of her bathroom here and on
that side it'd be like a sink that you
could
fill up ice makers with and make drinks
with i want to [ __ ] put a bar around
there and i want video games in there
and lights and yeah it's kind of like
we could do like a game like a game room
club type thing we just you know we
don't have friends over
you know grandfather's hammer said in
your basement you should build this
mushroom basement
florida we don't have basements in
florida because it'd be below the water
table yeah it would just be flooded all
the time
i think some houses do have basements
but
i grew up in a house that sort of had a
basement but it was like kind of above
like the house was actually raised off
the
ground yeah so the basement was like
half he's in michigan yeah that's what
i'm saying
we don't have no such thing no we don't
have basements
generally because you can't
like i said you dig down like a few feet
and it's just
it's like ocean water
we're right we're right at the water and
we're right at water level so well at
sea level bears and [ __ ] alligators
whole [ __ ] dinosaurs up in here man
dinosaurs dinosaurs alligator is a
dinosaur
look i gotta stay as con look we're
having a good show but we gotta stay
[ __ ] focused on the on the what do
you mean we you know you know you gotta
stay focused yeah that's not gonna
happen right
[Laughter]
i gave up on that a long time ago all
right so let's talk about bob ross like
i said we were talking about bob ross a
little bit like off and on how long
we've been on the show uh an hour and 12
minutes yeah it's time to go that's the
first hour's introduction basically
that's thank you all right
so interesting see i didn't even know
this until i looked this [ __ ] up this is
a small world bob ross who was actually
born robert norman ross so that is his
real name bob ross was born in
[ __ ] daytona beach florida
that's where i was born
so i thought that was kind of cool i'm
like hey
daytona bro
uh obviously he was born like much
earlier than i was he was born like in
the 1940s but yeah so as i said
everybody i kind of feel like everybody
in the world probably knows who bob ross
is that his [ __ ] show the joy of
painting was on
for
10 years more than 10 years it was it
was like 31
seasons but i think that there were
there was a season every quarter
so yeah so it was like a it was a while
1983 to 1994 it was on
um and
it went like eventually went like all
over europe and asia and everything like
that
so yeah he's born in daytona beach
florida which i thought was i was like
that's [ __ ] crazy there's because
obviously a lot of people are born in
daytona beach florida including me
but
you don't really hear about
famous people that were born in daytona
beach florida i can't really think i can
think of other famous people that were
born in florida
but i mean
well can i
tom petty i think he was born in
gainesville which is central florida
which is kind of central central florida
daytona is like on the coast
but
huh
i'm sure there's some
but i can't really think of eddie right
now
uh do women find his big ginger afro
sexy
um probably not but there's kind of a
funny story about that effort like why
he first did it and then like why he
kept it for so long that afro was
[ __ ] retro even in the 80s that she
was it was that was a 70s thing man and
i remember him out in california i was a
kid dudes have those afros
white dudes with afros
it was a bee geez type [ __ ] thing it
was just
it was kind of disco and
soft rock
weed
and um california girls that were kind
of dressed like [ __ ] indian girls
with the [ __ ] you know you see the
[ __ ]
you had to be there at the time to
understand what i'm talking about
you know it's hilarious speaking of the
bee gees when i was when we were in fye
the other day where i bought this cool
ass creep show shirt um they were
playing a bg's cd in there so the kids
did it yeah so the kids i was just kind
of like hey i like your bg's action here
dudes can sing like real nice disco
energy you have going in here
so i'm in there like looking around at
all the shirts like [ __ ] yeah doing
that like just listen to night fever if
you don't believe me [ __ ] knife
either [ __ ] yeah we i got dj's in
here [ __ ] dj maniac
he will attest [ __ ] the dgs had game and
they could [ __ ] do
you said the dg's the dg's they said the
beaches and bg's had game man they could
[ __ ] break that's that's the porn
cover version babe that's the dg's d for
dick she's [ __ ] with me
[Laughter]
it's my job yeah mrs evans already party
said i live in a 5400
square foot victorian that my hubby and
i renovated we can't afford to heat and
cool all of it it isn't practical but we
love it and our kids do too yeah i think
that's
she said what kills us all the
maintenance yeah and we do all what yeah
that's what i'm saying so it as much as
cool as it would be like i said to to
live out my fantasy of like living in
like an old creepy like hammer
horror house
but i could well i could do one like
that but like on a smaller scale because
like i said one i don't want to clean it
and i don't have to pay somebody else to
clean when i was living in mississippi
working in the [ __ ]
uh central heating and air [ __ ]
industry
uh my boss
my boss who is uh my dad's best friend
they grew up together
he called those victorians money eaters
and uh man
they would spend all kind of money to
get [ __ ] central [ __ ] heating and
air and those things because mississippi
is filled with those big old victorians
they're [ __ ] beautiful
two and three story how three-story ones
too
they're not very big but they're kind of
tall they look like
something out of the haunted mansion
uh but they were never designed for air
conditioning this had tall
open tall glass
door windows type things you could open
up and go around and walk around
balconies that went all the way around
each floor
and um
we would put [ __ ]
central systems in them and have to
[ __ ] make metal duct work to have it
all insulated and
all the duct works now on the outside of
the walls because the walls aren't thick
enough to hide the ductwork
you know
just
they're they are beautiful
but
they just were never designed to be
air conditioned and
if you want to air condition that you
better have some [ __ ] money
yeah we're just supposed to [ __ ] have
the windows open with screens oh my god
yeah what's up pokey
yeah
i can't brush you right now in the
middle of the show but the ones in the
ones all over mississippi uh the ones
that are still standing at least look
like something out of damn new orleans
they're real french looking you know
this hair is killing yeah
it's like all falling in my face and
stuff so
yeah
miss evans already party says our house
is super super creepy and i love it yeah
see i i want i want creepy that's why i
try to make it kind of creepy in here
it's not as creepy as i would like but
yeah
it's dark all the time i never ever
opened the blinds real high ceilings
with electric fans on them
that's the way they were
yeah so uh i don't know if you were here
but uh bob ross is from my hometown of
daytona beach florida oh you know
florida i did i didn't know he was from
daytona beach yeah i was like [ __ ] i
was born
that's cool so his dad was a carpenter
his mom was a waitress
uh and actually they moved to orlando uh
when he was so he actually he's a local
yeah so he actually grew up in orlando
so whoo somebody cool came from florida
that's nice there's a lot of cool people
from florida don't let jenny [ __ ] so
well somebody said grant through hammer
said fred durst of lit biscuits from
florida like that's not helping if
that's not helping matters okay bailey
manson's from florida
that's also not healthy it's tom petty's
from florida too yeah a lot of floor a
lot of people tom petty's kind of cool
florida's [ __ ] old it's older than
the united states
it is yeah
well yes like i said saint augustine is
the oldest uh continually occupied
european settlement yeah
so and it's a cool place to go it's one
of my favorite places to go that's where
i went for vacation last year
it's all vampiric and [ __ ] you know
lestat was from the south
okay
this kind of place you see lestat and
louise but they come from this places
like this
yeah we're thinking pirates everything's
covered with like spanish moss yeah
yeah that's the thing about florida is
that a lot of people because everybody
you know if you're not from here it's
just everything's like oh beaches and
everything we do have that but that's
not beaches in disney but yeah back in
the old days it was like creepy swamps
and spanish moss and pirates and yeah
[ __ ] like that so there is cool [ __ ]
empire they had an indian empire here a
bunch of bad asses
some of them were still here ran until
ran into one of them at the damn biker
bar
he was up in there i said you're a
seminar because yeah yeah i'm a seminar
but we stayed you know because a lot of
them got [ __ ]
back in the back in the seminole wars
they got sent to [ __ ] oklahoma or
whatever they didn't want to go because
they didn't want to live next to the
crow they couldn't stand the crow but
that's tribal history their seminole are
still here they're just americans now
there's a big ass uh seminole casino
yeah in lakeland yeah like on the way
it's between here and tampa when you see
one you know
they tend to be big seminoles were big
[ __ ] talk about six foot indians
all right and they're just chilled out
and
they hang out around here they tend to
be bikers they're country people got
farms
yeah richie wolfe said jim morrison was
from florida oh yeah i forgot about yeah
yeah he is a lot of cool people were
from florida
uh harold says where saint augustine
meaning like is that where we're talking
about saint augustine or where is one of
the places
saint augustine is like i said continue
the oldest continually occupied european
settlement in the united states and it's
about an hour and 15 minutes from here i
grew up like
like right i grew up in daytona beach
which is only like 40 50 miles down the
coast from you drive 40 50 miles up a1a
like right on the ocean and uh it's
right there and the the tip of florida
and [ __ ] the keys and everything
there was pirate [ __ ] going down going
on down there for [ __ ] centuries
all right well tampa on the west coast
they got the whole [ __ ] they got
gasparilla that's that whole like pirate
festival it's like mardi gras but it's
like pirate based they do that every
year yeah so florida isn't like
some kind of like uh generic hey we just
opened up shop last week no it's not
like that it's been it's been here for
[ __ ] ever
and it was spanish empire and the
[ __ ]
seminole empire and uh
long before america was ever here okay
it's it's uh i don't want to see a
diverse that's some kind of cheesy
[ __ ]
buzzword it's got character here got
character like new orleans and louisiana
you know imparts yeah a lot of character
imparts it's like that yeah yeah it has
the same kind of vibe yeah
granthar says question did bob ross pull
lots of strange with his painting stick
granthar thinks he was a wolf in sheep's
clothing you dropped more panties
talking about happy clowns burnt sienna
honestly he probably did um
[Music]
i don't know like i said they don't know
a great deal about his private life i
will get into that a little bit later
but
um
[Music]
he was married several times although
that that sounds like a little more
judgmental than it's because
the situation was a little bit uh
different than what you're maybe
picturing
but
he was
allegedly um
did kind of like cheat on some of his
wives
uh so there's that and
when he started getting famous
oh he absolutely had [ __ ] groupies i
don't know i don't know if he humped any
of them but oh yeah whoa i'm saying this
man's gonna cash in on his fame well i
kind of feel well i mean the thing about
him though is that his appeal seems
yeah he had like a bunch of like old
ladies and [ __ ] like that but
they had i saw this footage of he did um
like a live painting demonstration in uh
central park in new york city
and i don't remember what year it was
and they were like amazed at how many
people showed up and it was like
everybody like it was little kids it was
old ladies it was like young people it
was like [ __ ] everybody and they all
brought like paintings so it's like
everybody was watching the [ __ ] i
mentioned it in other shows my aunt lois
from mammoth mountain poultry guys
worked at palomar university palomar
observatory okay
and she worked for dr penner she was dr
penner's secretary back in those days
when you said a woman was a secretary
that was that was saying it's something
[ __ ] badass because she was the
laptop basically because the super
computer of the day all right they
didn't have laptops he had secretaries
they kept all that [ __ ] ordered she she
said
biggest babe magnet she ever saw was
carl sagan
okay
carl sagan was the [ __ ] man
they had sagan astronomy groupies okay
they had women [ __ ] gunning for that
i could see it but you know that's
he was he he also was another guy that
had the amsr style voice all right and
intelligent talent and intelligence
women like it they like it
and they i mean they also like character
character and somebody that is a
genuinely good person and like i said
bob ross always seemed like a genuinely
good dude yeah i mean he didn't seem
like he wasn't gonna [ __ ] shout at
you he wasn't gonna like [ __ ] he
wasn't gonna be a dick or nothing like
that segment was gonna sit down with you
and we're gonna talk about billions and
billions and billions that's what i mean
a lot of women are really into that
so i kind of feel like maybe it depends
on the woman like i said i'm not you
know generalized because everybody kind
of likes something different but
i know there's kind of like a
misconception
you know maybe in the in cell community
or whatever that it's like oh women only
like these kind of like jerks or people
that are like alphas or whatever and
that is absolutely not true um a lot of
women do not like those types of dudes
uh you know so there's that
and
i it would not surprise me i don't know
if it really happened or not but it
would not surprise me if bob ross i mean
for sure like he had a lot of uh female
fans and honestly in uh in the netflix
documentary i think his son was saying
that at one point like at the height of
his fame he would go and do classes or
he would go and do um you know live
demonstrations like in malls and [ __ ]
like that and
so many people would show up and like
women would show up and they they would
be like a rock star they would like try
to like tear his shirt off and [ __ ] like
that so um he absolutely did have
groupies i mean despite his hair
which you'd think might be a detriment
but
it was uh
the thing about it was that it was just
like a part of him his hair got to be so
much a part of him that when i see
pictures because there were pictures of
him before he got the perm because it
was a perm before he got it
when he was younger like in like
military photos and stuff and i can't
recognize him
without the hair i guess because the
afro is just so prominent that i never
really like looked at his face like all
that
it was just kind of like he was just
like a little ball of hair like a little
dandelion and i never really like looked
at his face all that closely and i
didn't really realize that until i
started seeing pictures of him i said if
you showed me a picture of that and be
like hey who's that i would have no idea
because i never like looked at his face
enough to like recognize his features
without i mean his hair was just like so
recognizable that that was kind of like
all you could realize so it's like when
you see pictures of him
from before he had that
um when he because back when he was
younger he used to have kind of like a
pompadour which is actually pretty cool
and he looked kind of rockabilly and he
so he had that i said if you showed me a
picture of that and said that's bob ross
or asked me who it was i would have no
idea who that was because i can't
recognize him without that [ __ ] afro
you know
and i he they they were savvy enough to
know that that was like his trademark
you know
and
you know it probably would have been the
same thing if he had different hair it'd
be like who the [ __ ] is that guy you
know what i mean where's the afro
uh but yeah so he grew up in orlando
florida now
one of the other things like other than
painting the other thing that he was
really really really into was
animals he loved animals he loved
wildlife he was really into even in his
later years um he had kind of like uh he
would rescue he had like a wildlife
rescue
um you know where he would help out with
wildlife rescues and obviously you grew
up in florida you know we have he he
called him critters just like we were
talking about that the other day yeah um
and he had little pet animals like all
the time
uh you know he would
rescue little alligators and armadillos
and snakes he had a pet snake for a
while and [ __ ] like that crater is a
florida
bee wolf okay which uh if you didn't see
the other show about [ __ ] um
north men you'll understand what a bee
wolf was
but b wolf meant critter
critter
couldn't mean bear but any kind of any
kind of predator was a bee wolf
a big wolf
hugo said in the new creep show series
there's a character based on bob ross
which is hilarious yeah that's right i
had forgotten about that yeah in the
last creep show series which is on uh
shutter
they had an episode that had like that
was set at like a public tv station and
they had a character that's based on bob
ross yeah jim morrison was from
melbourne
yeah that's um melbourne is like a
little bit
how many miles like maybe 30 40 miles
south of where i grew up so yeah
um hugo said i went to art school
because of bob ross and ray harryhausen
ray harry house so there you go with the
stop motion stuff man i mean the sin
beds that's awesome yeah
that's awesome
i mean
those are like two really good heroes to
have i feel like you need to bring back
stop motion [ __ ] all this cgi use cg to
make stop motion look better to get the
[ __ ] blur in between frames that's
how i would do it i was always real into
stop-motion it doesn't matter it doesn't
have to look real no just i don't care
if it looks real it just just looks good
yeah i don't know i liked it as a kid
because it didn't look real like yeah it
means like a moving toy
i mean and i even got into i mean you
know obviously like nightmare before
christmas and all that kind of stuff but
i was always into like nick nick park
where he did like wallace and grommet
and stuff like that i mean that [ __ ]
looks amazing yeah all that all that uh
stop-motion animation is like fantastic
i love those wallace and gromit shorts
and then they did like long they did
long-form movies to like chicken run and
curse of the wear rabbit and all that
kind of stuff that we're all stop motion
it's it's really like
yeah it's time consuming but
you're making a piece of art you know
i'm not [ __ ] on like digital artists
because that's like a thing too but it's
easier
let's not yeah it's tedious but it's
easier
so i kind of respect anybody that
actually like makes the little puppets
and like moves them and does you know
well it was also in empire strikes back
a return of the jedi remember they were
doing a lot of uh stop-motion
stop-motion walkers stop-motion
tauntauns and [ __ ] i just thought it
looked good it did yeah yeah like i said
it doesn't look entirely real but that's
okay yeah i know you just it's just
fantasy movie anyway yeah
i mean yeah it was the same thing with
like a [ __ ] like uh you know like clash
of the titans which also had like ray
harry house and stuff and it's like you
know it didn't look real but you just
incorporated into your whole like
experience of the movie so it would
rubble
yeah
with ed209 and yeah people have
imagination it's okay it doesn't have to
look completely realistic if it's
especially if it's a fantasy movie yep
um dj maniac says like al jorgensen
before the weave exactly if you showed
me a picture of al jorgensen and he
didn't have that hair
i would not recognize him and it's the
same thing with bob ross i see pictures
like old like i know it's bob ross
obviously because i'm watching a
documentary about bob ross
but if you just showed me a picture of
that dude randomly and said who's this
i wouldn't know who it was because he
didn't have the afro yet so
grandpa's asking me where would bob ross
land on the manly man scale
is there such a thing
no yeah of course there is
of course there is these are
ridiculous course there is
but the thing is that there's always
another scale
okay
i've [ __ ] been through some of the
[ __ ] most manliest man [ __ ]
life american life can offer all right
[ __ ]
military and government type [ __ ]
there's an other kind of man
okay
you can't put
mozart on the same scale
as you know what i mean [ __ ] uh
somebody like
masada ube or something or actually
he's a writer so that's not the same uh
not you can't judge them all you can't
judge all men the same way they got some
dudes that just can come out with some
artistic [ __ ] that's like oh yeah hell
yeah so the man credits just go way up
all right
now ross bob ross
he had the amsr factor all right he had
he could paint
uh he could relax you
said no he was no he was seated and he
was just he seemed like a just a
genuinely good dude he was just a nice
man right and we don't really have a lot
of those or we don't have examples of
those i'm sure there's lots of nice
people so he carved out a niche for
himself and uh and
making up your own rules and mastering
your own game is a macho [ __ ] thing
and that's that's what and it obviously
struck a chord because people are still
talking about him decades after he died
yeah you know uh it's it's uh
part of the big man bonus points is not
to follow but to innovate and to make
your own way
not every dude is doing that
to me the manliest thing is to not give
a [ __ ] where you fall on the manly man
scale that is the main link well no no
no no
no everybody not give a [ __ ] about what
other people think about you
that's what i mean it's just not you
don't you do your own [ __ ] right don't
like worry about what other people are
saying
you cannot conf
you can it is not super manly
to confine yourself to stereotypes
of what the manly man scale is you know
what it is when you see it
you know what it is when it see it you
know it when you see it
and sometimes the dude can innovate and
just come up with something
you the man you the [ __ ] man all
right
now there's different kinds there's
going to be different reactions and the
women are going to react differently but
that's what life is about
it's not stereotypical stuff
like for instance okay look
this
we're gonna speak we're gonna speak
amongst the same generation
was prince a tough dude no prince was
not tough was prince could prince bench
press what i pressed no was prince a man
yeah prince was mad if prince was a
[ __ ] man all right prince could do
things that i could not do
and [ __ ]
make a lot of money
and uh get a lot of [ __ ] appreciation
from other men
because of his words and his art
and uh could [ __ ] um
have entire [ __ ] just armies of
females [ __ ] listening to his albums
and [ __ ] females females women women
not females just [ __ ] loving on this
okay
so was prince
no a female is just
women are women have problems with
science okay but no we don't okay it's
just all these females just [ __ ]
loving this dude
and uh is he a stereotypical manly man
no not at all not at all
was he manly yeah yeah he was he was
rewriting it
he did it his own way
uh he did it in a way that worked so no
a [ __ ] prince was the [ __ ] man yeah
he was great
would i do that no
but that was him
you know
have i done stuff kind of like that
within the goth world yeah
but you see he was working within his
own framework of talent
he was applying himself
the best way he could
and yeah he got a lot of success for it
he died from uh some drug addiction
from on prescription drugs but a lot of
those guys did
you know that's how elvis went
it was sad it was sad because he there
was still a lot more in him
he could he you know there was there
were there was more music in him
just that we didn't get it
well whatever mr 88 says what is sad
is there are not enough nice men yeah i
agree when they are many jump to they
must be buggerers yeah uh it's very
difficult to find the zone society is
very cynical yeah and the thing is you
can't like blame people for thinking
that because a lot of times it's like oh
i met this person and they were like
seemed really nice but then it turned
out that they were
you know a serial killer or just you
know maybe not that extreme obviously
but they turned out to be like an
[ __ ] or they sucked in some way
so i understand that and like i said i
kind of feel like that's why people like
bob ross or mr rogers or something like
that like still resonate to this day
is because those dudes were like
genuinely nice dudes and nothing bad
ever came out about them like i know
that some people maybe try to say oh
maybe they're a child molester but it
really never seemed to stick you know
what i mean because everybody
knew them and are like no they were just
like a genuinely nice person and i kind
of feel like it's sad that most people
and i don't know if this is actually
true or not but most people feel like oh
i never meet anybody that's just like a
genuinely nice person
or you know everybody's got like some
[ __ ] dark secret or they seem like a
nice person and then you find out like
some really shitty stuff that they did
or said or like something like that like
back in the day it's like why can't
anybody just be a genuinely nice person
but i do kind of feel like that's why
bob ross still
you know this many years after his death
like why people still talking about the
same thing with mr rogers because they
just seem like genuinely nice ass people
which as i said it really does seem
rare i'm sure it's not
but it just seems that way just because
so many of us me included have had
you know experiences where you meet
somebody that seems like a genuinely
nice person and then like later on you
find out they're shitty in some way or
another and after a while that starts to
wear on you and you've gotta get to a
point where well every nice person well
they must be hiding something that
nobody could be this nice of a person so
yeah you do get kind of cynical but
there are people out there that are that
nice it's just that you know people have
been burned so many times that yeah but
yeah but you also have to back up and
realize that
when you're talking about
bob ross and you're talking about
um
[ __ ] mr rogers there was a medium
involved which is television okay
that if if television wasn't involved
those got two two guys you'd never even
know their names they just came across
that media the right way
to bring a bunch of fans yeah um were
they good dudes yeah they're good dudes
and they knew how they knew how to
capitalize on what they had
now blairdo's going on about what was
this um
um [ __ ] where'd he go
uh chuck uh chuck norris being able to
swim across the atlantic without getting
wet no yeah okay the thing about chuck
norris is that chuck norris was a meme
and the army guys in the army made chuck
norris memes and chuck norris got mad
about him for a while it took a while
for chuck norris to embrace chuck norris
jokes to pull the stick out of it which
is funny which is a which is which is
yeah
he didn't have much of a sense of humor
right
which tells you right there that chuck
norris is a bit of an [ __ ] okay he
doesn't really understand anything
and um he's like super super super
christian
yeah that's not the problem no i mean
well no i mean like the problem nobody
can swear around me
yeah person he's very very up-to-date
the problem with him is that
it's going to be more than that though
you know i mean he he doesn't understand
humor
yeah he's super uptight
which makes me think that he's not as
authentic
as you think he is because of course his
movies are fake as [ __ ] all right chuck
norris will get his ass whipped
in an mma fight
a pro mma fighter would [ __ ] him up
but he came from a time before mma all
right
but you know a boxer could probably [ __ ]
his ass up
i did we talked about this in other
[ __ ] shows about martial arts martial
arts weren't as real as we thought they
were when we were kids they were it's
fantasy
partially even
even
heaven forbid even [ __ ] um
bruce lee
is not as authentic as you think all
right he was good
bruce was fast
but bruce will get his ass whipped all
right uh by by an mma fighter
you know
now could bruce be retrained as an mma
fighter yeah he could have he he was
good he had talent
but he was a man of his time you know
what i mean and
yeah a real big [ __ ] pic [ __ ]
bruce lee up throw his ass crosstalk
he didn't weigh anything he only weighed
145 pounds all right
um
it's hard to beat a dude who can pick
you up
and throw you
been there and done that okay
you just can't get the leverage you need
to apply any power to the dude's head
the leverage is coming off the ground i
mean he's picked you up you're instantly
weaker because you just you do oh i
gotta go to the restroom yeah he's
getting bored well yeah you're going on
and on i thought you
i only i got like 10 into my notes mr 88
though said one chuck norris joke which
i haven't heard before chuck norris
didn't dial the wrong number you
answered the wrong phone
i never heard that one i've heard most
of the chuck norris memes but that's the
new one that's actually pretty funny so
yeah so where was i i just didn't even
get that much pass like bob ross was
born in [ __ ] daytona beach and then
we got all sidetracked so as i said he
was super super into like animal welfare
like wildlife and stuff and he actually
like did an animal rescue like later on
he would rescue injured animals and
nurse them back to health and release
them into the wild later on we had a tv
show matter of fact and i kind of
remember this too from when i was a kid
for like i think it was two years he had
this little squirrel that he had rescued
uh which i also kind of related to
because i had the same thing too like a
baby squirrel like fell out of a really
tall tree and i rescued it his eyes
weren't even open yet and we kept him
like for a long time
and uh so yeah so he had one too and the
squirrel's name was peapod and he used
to bring him on the show like in his
pocket and so he had him for two years
and then he released him into the wild
so i thought that was like kind of cool
but yeah he was really really into
animal welfare and you know nursing
animals back to health he also had a
half brother named jim who will come
into play later on
uh interestingly bob ross dropped out of
high school in the ninth grade
um
he actually apprenticed to his dad who
was a carpenter now when he was
apprenticing with his dad he actually
lost
an index finger or like part of his
index finger on his left hand you never
really noticed it on the show like i
didn't know that he didn't have part of
his finger like on his left hand
but when i saw like one documentary that
kind of showed like a close-up
of his hand like in the
uh in the palette you could see that
like half of his left in the index
finger was gone but they said because it
was his left hand and not as right that
it didn't really you know it wasn't
really that like big deal
so in 1961 when uh bob ross was 18 he
enlisted in the air force now he was
actually put into service as a medical
records technician and ended up rising
to the rank of master sergeant
so he was so he mostly grew up in
florida but then uh he served as first
sergeant of the clinic at the one of the
air force base in alaska
now interestingly he had obviously never
seen snow before because he grew up in
florida so he didn't uh he said he never
saw snow until he was 21 and i was like
hey same i was also born in daytona
beach and i did not see snow until i was
22 years old the first time i went to
the uk because it doesn't [ __ ] snow
here so you know uh you know i've never
seen mountains either because we also
don't have mountains
so there's that
uh so
one of his quotes this is quite famous
uh because he had a lot of positions in
the military when he was in there for a
long time he had to act like kind of
mean and tough and everything and he
said i was the guy who makes you makes
you scrub the latrine the guy who makes
you make your bed the guy who screams at
you for being late to work and he
decided if you know when he retired from
the military he was never going to be
like that ever again because he didn't
really like having to like [ __ ] yell
at people all the time
so he was in the air force for actually
uh 20 years
and he first developed his interest in
art he had attended an art class
at the uso club in anchorage
and one of the things though was that at
the time i guess this is you know in the
50s and 60s most of his art instructors
were real into like abstract art because
that was kind of the thing at the time
and he kind of wanted to paint more
traditional stuff and so i kind of feel
like they you know so he was always kind
of like at odds with them about that uh
one of his quotes was they'd tell you
what makes a tree but they wouldn't tell
you how to paint a tree so there's that
kind of thing too
but the thing about it i mean i took a
bunch of art classes in high school and
college one thing that my teacher always
told me
uh that i thought was really good
because i know that a lot of people
there's kind of a thing
between people that paint like
traditional representational art and
people that do more like abstract art
and the thing about it is that
abstract art is not just like throwing a
bunch of [ __ ] on the canvas and like
thinking because anybody can do that
but
mostly the abstract artists that become
famous or become well-known or beloved
or whatever
usually like learned the traditional way
first my teacher used to say you have to
know all the rules before you can break
them you can't just like come out and be
like hey look it's a piece of abstract
art you know what i mean
it's not going to fly you have to know
all the rules and know which ones you're
breaking so it there's a lot more
thought to it than
than i thought but the thing about bob
ross later on he would kind of make
little did he wasn't like a mean person
but he would always like make little
digs about
like he would uh you know put his canvas
up on his show and then he'd just like
do some background [ __ ] or whatever like
just a couple colors and then he's like
there we go it's ready to go in the
museum of modern art you know what i
mean where it was just like a couple
colors so he was kind of like making fun
but
you know
it's it's an easy joke to make i've been
in the museum of modern art several
times and it's like uh yeah there is
some art that looks like that but a lot
of it doesn't look like that so you know
what i mean i know it's an easy joke to
make though like making fun of like
modern art [ __ ]
uh okay so
while bob was still in the military
he was also working as a bartender
part-time
uh kind of to make ends meet you know
and one day when he's in the bar
the tv is on and it's on pbs and he sees
this little show called the magic of oil
painting
this was hosted by a german fella named
bill alexander now like i said i had
seen this dudes this dude was also like
really famous back in the day i kind of
feel like bob ross
uh supplanted him a little bit and i
think that he was a little bitter about
that
um
which like i said we'll get into that
but i remember bill alexander's show too
and he was actually really successful
like his show was on all the time he had
like his own line of books he had his
own line of paints and like painting
kits and painting supplies and [ __ ] like
that so
you know and he taught classes as well
um and bob ross was like really
interested in this because bill
alexander
was using a technique
uh widely known as a la prima which
i kind of feel like bill later he went a
little off the deep end and said he
invented this he absolutely did not um
that it actually came from the 16th
century and a lot of famous artists uh
have used it
alaprima is italian for essentially like
at first attempt
normally i don't know if you know a lot
about oil painting but oil painting oil
paints take a long time to dry generally
so in traditional oil painting what you
would do is you would paint a layer like
the background layer for example and
then you would wait until it dried and
it would usually take several days a
week it would take a while depending on
how much paint and thinner you'd used
and then once it was completely dry you
would come in and do another layer and
then wait for that to dry and then come
in and you would do that until the
painting was completed a la prima
is basically they say it's like wet on
wet which
it kind of is wet on wet you don't
really have to do the same the whole
thing like in one session
uh but alla prima is usually done in one
session but other than it's pretty much
the same what you're doing is
you're essentially using the paint
you're just doing all of it like at once
so you're doing like the background but
you're using using like wetter paint and
just kind of doing stuff all in one
session instead of waiting for stuff to
dry like in between layers and you can
get is if you know what you're doing you
can get like a lot of really interesting
like blending effects when you do it
like that as i said uh this had been
developed i think it flanders like back
in the 50s 1500s early 16th century
whenever it was so bill alexander didn't
invent the [ __ ] but bob ross had never
seen it before and he sees this guy on
tv doing it like doing a painting like a
landscape painting in like [ __ ] half
an hour and he's like that shit's
amazing um i want to learn to do that
so uh yeah so as i said it's not a new
technique van gogh used it velasque has
used it um the impressionists used it
anybody that like paints uh outdoors
they usually use it so you know it's
kind of like a thing where you want to
be like spontaneous you're painting
something outside like getting a
landscape [ __ ] like that
so basically what you do
um
ross uh bob ross was kind of like well
i want to train with that guy
so he goes to take classes
from that guy
from bill alexander and the two of them
actually became friends
and bob became like a really good
uh you know he pretty much mastered the
technique obviously because he had like
a really successful show
which ended up like i said
supplanting poor old bill alexander even
though he was doing essentially the same
thing
so after he learned how to do it from
bill
he's still working at the bar
so one thing that he started to do and
he was in alaska so he would start doing
these landscape paintings
on like the bottoms of these uh like
gold you know like the pans where you
pan for gold so he would do like
landscape paintings on the bottoms of
those and he would like put him up on
the wall of the bar and he would like
sell him like for extra money
now eventually he was selling so many of
these
uh that
that he made uh more money than the
military was paying him
uh and as i said he'd been in there for
a while so in 1981 he retired from the
air force
he was a master sergeant as i mentioned
earlier
now at this point uh he had had one wife
prior
with whom he had had his son steve
and she either she divorced him
she either divorced him or she passed
away i can't remember but um
[Music]
he did have some affairs allegedly which
might have been one of the reasons she
divorced him but he married somebody uh
his second wife jane
so he was married to jane and
jane and his son by his first wife steve
they actually said okay well we're gonna
stay here in alaska
but jane gave him a thousand dollars and
said you go if you want to pursue this
painting thing
then i'm all about it here's a thousand
dollars go and try to do something with
that
and bob said okay um you know i'm gonna
go out and try to make my fortune at
this if i can't do it like within x
amount of time
then i'll come back and just like get a
regular job or whatever so he sets out
to do that
so as i said he had trained with bill
alexander and he actually ended up
working for uh bill alexander had his
own company like an art supply company
as i said he had
you know contracts with
companies that made
paints and various art supplies and had
like his branding on them that's what he
where he made most of his money that and
the books and the classes that he taught
so bob ross goes to work for that
company and started traveling around the
country um
as a traveling salesman and he was also
teaching classes so he was like teaching
other people the alaprima technique that
bill alexander had
i guess showed him how to do like and
did on tv
now eventually bill decided to retire
not from the tv show he was still doing
that but he decided to retire from
traveling around doing classes
so what he decided to do he said okay
well
bob was at that point like a certified
bill alexander alla prima style
instructor so he's like why don't you
take over my classes
because you're so good at it
now
faithfully in 1982
he was doing a five-day workshop in
florida
uh you know obviously where he was from
originally and he ended up meeting
annette and walt kowalski and these two
would be his business partners up until
he died and
uh i think
they're still alive amazingly
um and as i said they seem a little
touchy about uh bob ross's image and
[ __ ] like that like you know and now
that he's dead so
yeah um as i said the netflix
documentary is not real flattering to
them so
a lot of the stuff i'm saying is just
coming from people like from the netflix
documentary and [ __ ] like that but we'll
get into that
now what did up how they ended up
meeting was that annette and walt uh one
of their sons unfortunately had died in
a car accident
and annette
was
so distraught that she just kind of like
checked out and apparently she was just
like laying around on the couch
all day
watching bill alexander paint on pbs
like that was the only thing that made
her feel any better
so her husband walt says well i'm gonna
buy you know uh we'll drive down to
florida and i'll get you a five-day
workshop with this bill alexander dude
you live so much maybe that will make
you like feel a little bit better
so so he did that
however she didn't know
that bill alexander had retired from
doing the classes and it passed off his
classes to this [ __ ] nobody named bob
ross so she finds out that this
guy who she never heard of is teaching
the class and she's really bummed out
about it because she thought it was
going to be bill who she'd been watching
on tv
but they decided well you know we
already paid for the ship we were
already going down to florida because
they were from virginia or like
washington dc virginia area
so he's like we already paid for the
[ __ ] so let's just go down there
so they go down to take the class
annette goes in the class and she says
within like five minutes
of bob ross talking and like teaching
how to paint
she was like mesmerized
and she said immediately we knew this
dude is like something special and like
walt said something because there was an
interview with them on this other
documentary that i watched that it's
like whatever this dude has we need to
figure out how to what did he say bottle
it like bottle it and sell it
which is essentially what they did
but they recognized that he really had
something that could really go
get popular
so
she does the class for a week and at the
end of the week they said okay well come
to dinner with us we have a proposition
for you because they apparently had some
money and that they were gonna invest
and they really did like believe in him
so they're like okay well
uh we want you to go into business with
us um
you know we want you to teach classes up
here like around in our stomping ground
like up around virginia washington dc
area so he said okay
so they first start out trying to sell
these courses
um
and at first i think they were just
running like newspaper ads generally
and
the first few classes that they ran they
actually had to cancel them because
nobody signed up
because nobody knew who the [ __ ] bob
ross is which is like hilarious to think
of now because everybody in the [ __ ]
world knows who he is but back then bill
alexander was the famous guy but bill
alexander was not
doing classes anymore he retired from
that he still had the tv show but he
wasn't doing the classes so this guy bob
ron who the [ __ ] is that nobody knows
but they tried to set up they bought
like uh you know newspaper ads they did
like demonstrations in the mall and [ __ ]
like that like you did back in the 80s
everybody be in the mall um but it
didn't really work like nobody really uh
showed up
now at this point uh i guess bob still
had some of the money that his wife had
given him
and this is the point where the infamous
perm comes into the thing because he had
normal hair
prior to this
but i guess he reasoned
that because he didn't have a lot of
money for haircuts
that if he got his hair permed then it
would be like less maintenance and it
would be like cheaper like he wouldn't
have to go get it like cut all the time
so he got it permed
now interestingly like he had it perm
for a while and then like after a while
he got sick of it and he hated it and he
wanted to change his hair but he felt
like he couldn't because it had become
his trademark by that point
and
as i said if he changed his hair then
nobody would recognize him anymore so he
just had to keep it like that until the
day he [ __ ] died even though he
couldn't stand it like i'm sure he liked
it at some point because he got it but
then after a while he seemed like he was
like trapped into it because that was
like his image that was his thing and he
couldn't change it but the initial
reason he got it at least according to
everybody that i saw said because he
thought it would save money because it
was it would be less maintenance he
wouldn't need to like get haircuts all
the time so i thought that was like kind
of funny another thing that i thought
was kind of funny was according to uh
some of his friends they said whenever
he would go back to the hairdresser to
get like it re-permed he always called
it getting his springs tightened
that like i don't know why that made me
laugh so hard but like the first time i
was like oh that's so cute he was so
cute
uh so yeah
so the classes that they did at first
like nobody showed up
now one class uh they had this is
according to the documentary the happy
painter which is on youtube
uh they said they had this one class
where one dude showed up
right one dude and it was like an
evening class because at first they were
like they were doing classes during the
day and then they were like well maybe
everybody's at work like let's do some
evening classes they started doing
evening classes but nobody really showed
up for those either but there's one
class they did they just like one dude
showed up
and the kowalski's were like we're not
doing a class just for one dude but bob
ross said no we are going to do a class
just this one dude so he did this whole
class just teaching this one dude how to
paint
now apparently according to
this documentary
the guy was so impressed
that bob had actually taken his time
like and did this class and just to
teach him specifically how to paint and
was like so cool and like humble about
it
he said i tell you what um you know i'm
a businessman you know i have a [ __ ] ton
of money i don't i'm sure he didn't say
that but he's like i i'll tell you what
he's like i will give you i'll offer you
a million dollar contract right now if
like from now on you give me 40 of every
of all of your takings you know what i
mean
which to me i'd have been like yes
please cough it up
but
bob and the kowalski said no
because they had their own [ __ ] going
and they said no we think this is going
places so thank you but no thank you
they didn't take it
i mean i guess that it worked out good
for them in the end but i kind of feel
like
in the moment i've probably been like a
million dollars okay yeah
what do you want
now so what they decided to do they said
okay well maybe we should do some tv
commercials so what they did
was they said okay well bill alexander
is the famous guy right and it's like
you're doing his style
and but nobody knows who the [ __ ] you
are so let's do some commercials where
bill alexander
like
passes the torch essentially like he'll
hand over his two-inch brush and be
here's my almighty brush as he used to
say he'll hand that over to you and say
you know you're the next anointed
whatever like of my method and maybe
that will like it because it's a famous
person and you're a not famous person so
you know that's how we're gonna work
that out
so they made a commercial like that and
they ran because like the kowalski's
you know as shitty as like a lot of the
stuff that people said about them and
i'm you know it maybe is probably true
um
initially they did believe in bob ross
enough i don't i don't know how rich
they were at the time that this was all
going on but they were apparently rich
enough to like pour a [ __ ] ton of money
into his career at first
and not really being assured of any
return so they did have a lot of
confidence in him
so they basically paid
for this commercial to be made
they paid for the commercial to run
before and after bill alexander's show
because they actually did find because
normally i don't know if you know how if
you're not in the u.s um you know public
television obviously they don't they
have donors and stuff like that but they
don't run ads but there were like a
handful of pbs stations in the country
some of them were in the midwest like in
muncie indiana and stuff that were
allowed to run like a certain percentage
of ads so they found that market and
they said okay we're gonna run the ad
for your class before and after bill
alexander's show and they also paid for
this commercial to run during phil
donahue's show which was like massive
back then i'm sure that was probably not
cheap because that was like a really
really big like daytime talk show back
in the 80s
so they ran that
and
that was
super super successful the fact that his
name was associated with bill alexander
the fact of you know everybody seeing
the ads so that like really really
helped and the classes started filling
up and getting like really really
successful
now how he got ended up getting a tv
show
was kind of interesting
1983
bob and annette kowalski
they show up at this
public broadcasting station in virginia
and initially they just went there
because they wanted to record some more
commercials
for some of their upcoming classes they
wanted to buy that
so when they were there like filming the
commercials the station manager i think
saw what bob was doing like painting the
[ __ ] and he's like holy crap that's
amazing
um
we should do a show
like you know can you do a show and
bob's like sure like how many episodes
do you want it's like we if we could do
13 episodes that's like a season and
he's like okay absolutely we can do that
here's the problem though
um and this is maybe one of the reasons
because at first when i was reading some
of the [ __ ] like about bill alexander
and how like uh tetchy he got about
stuff later on i was kind of like man
what [ __ ] but the more i kind of
looked into it i was like uh well he's
still kind of [ __ ] but
i could kind of see where he was coming
from
because the thing about it was that he
didn't
okay he taught bob ross
that method if you see the bill
alexander show and i'm sure they're
probably on youtube because i used to
watch that on pbs as well and if you see
bob ross's thing i mean the technique is
exactly the same
um you know bob ross learned from bill
alexander but the thing about it is that
bob ross even took a lot of his like his
catch phrases like happy little trees
happy little clouds um you know [ __ ]
like that
he took that from bill alexander bill
alexander said that shut now it is true
that their um personalities were like
diametrically opposed as i mentioned
bill alexander was like very
brusque he was very boisterous he was
loud he was um you know he was always
kind of like stabbing at them he was
like almighty brush
and so he was kind of like that he was
always kind of yelling like not in a
mean way but he was just like really
like excitable whereas bob ross was like
super chill but a lot of the stuff that
bob ross said and did
was very very similar to what bill
alexander said and did you know what i
mean which it's not surprising because
it was like a mentor situation
but
i kind of feel like in later years bill
alexander thought he completely stole
like all my shtick
and got more famous than me
and then like bill alexander like hardly
anybody remembers anymore i feel like
and everybody knows who bob ross is so i
could see how maybe you might be a
little bitter about that um you know so
so there's that
and the and the whole thing too i don't
think bill alexander because you know
how bob ross would always he'd like you
know beat the um the paint brush and he
always say able to beat the devil out of
it and then he'd kind of laugh
um i don't know if bill alexander
because i haven't seen all of the shows
but i don't think he ever said beat the
della but but he did sit do something
similar like he would do the same thing
and he would say like he had a little
catch phrase about it so bob ross did
take a lot of his stick from bill
alexander that is true and like i said
that um that method is pretty much
exactly the same
so uh so yeah so the problem was that
bill alexander was totally fine
with
you know being bob ross's friend and
doing commercials for him and stuff like
that when he was just
teaching classes
in that alla prima method
because bill alexander was not teaching
classes anymore he had retired from that
however
bill alexander still had a tv show
and he still had his own line of
painting supplies
and it was kind of i don't know if this
was i don't think it was any kind of
like contract or anything but i think it
was like an unspoken agreement
that
you know yeah i'll help you out as long
as you're not like stepping on my dick
type of thing
so the fact that bob ross and the
kowalski's like went and got a tv show
that was doing the same thing that bill
alexander was doing and was like in
direct competition with him now
um kind of made him mad and then like
later on
when
the kowalski's were like hey you know
how bill alexander has his own line of
paints and paint supplies and stuff
maybe we should do that too and then
bill alexander was like for [ __ ] sake
because i thought you guys were not
gonna he's like i was
i was helping you because you know you
weren't competing with me because i
wasn't i wasn't teaching classes anymore
but now you're directly competing with
me because you're you have a tv show
also and now you also have your own line
of paints which are competing with me so
like i said uh you know when i before i
looked too much into it i said wow bill
alexander sounds like a dick but now i
can kind of understand like where he was
coming from i don't know how much of
this was coming from bob ross though and
some of it might have been coming from
the kowalski's because they seemed like
bob ross according to everybody that
knew him
he just wanted to paint and he just
wanted to teach people to paint he
didn't really give that much of a [ __ ]
about business or money or anything like
that so i kind of feel like the
kowalski's were the ones that were kind
of like
doing that you know what i'm saying so
we're maybe pushing for that and like
maybe bob ross like went along with it
it's like yeah okay whatever i see what
you're doing but
i don't know if he would have
necessarily done that on his own like i
said i wasn't there i didn't know them
but i'm just saying that was the
impression that i got
so they kind of just fell ass backwards
into a tv show when they went to this tv
station to like film a commercial and
they were just kind of like yeah that's
cool but like i said because it was
public tv you don't get paid for the
doing the tv shows right i mean you get
paid for like supplemental [ __ ] the tv
shows are basically like an
advertisement for your
live classes where people come and learn
from you your workshops um you know and
if you do books or if you you know sell
paints or [ __ ] like that so that's where
you're making your money not making
money from the tv show directly
so yeah so the show was recorded at uh
this public television station in muncie
indiana
and
basically what
bob at first
wanted which is really funny i saw some
of the sketches like on this documentary
he initially wanted like a background
that looked like a studio set that
looked like a hunting lodge
um
but then and they were like
they're probably like what where do you
think we're getting this money from but
uh this is a [ __ ] pbs station because
i kind of feel like i mean the the show
it was basically shot in the living room
of a house i mean it's it's a public tv
station but it's a house it's like a
converted old house it's a cool looking
building but it's like just an old house
and they're like so we basically were in
the living room like this yeah they were
in the living room and it's like you
know the black curtain in the background
they're like we put the black curtain in
the background to cover up the fireplace
that was where the fireplace was and uh
so you only had like a few feet
but in the end uh bob decided well no he
liked that better because it was like
less distracting and he felt like it
gave like a more intimate
kind of uh thing with the viewer like it
was just you know it was smaller there
was nothing in the background to kind of
draw your eye it was just him talking to
you and there was that kind of [ __ ]
now the paintings as i said were all
done
actually in between 26 and 30 minutes
with minimal edits the only time they
would edit is if something technically
went wrong or you know if like some [ __ ]
fell over or something like that um
basically what you saw on there like
campaigning it there were there was no
trickery there was nothing like that he
painted the whole thing in that amount
of time
however he didn't just pull the [ __ ] out
of his head
uh what he would do
usually except for the second season
because that was a whole other thing but
he would usually
decide what paintings he was going to do
for that season like i said so it was 13
shows
and he would paint versions of all of
them beforehand
and then when he would go to record that
show he'd put it like he'd put that one
in like the in the background so he
could see it like to refer to
but he was like don't ever show anybody
that the the guide painting that's like
off camera he's like because in case i
don't have time to like finish the one
that he's doing live and like you know
what if i didn't put the cabin in there
or something like that he didn't want
like everybody getting mad but he did
have another painting like over there
that he was looking at so it wasn't just
like pulling it out of his butt you know
what i mean so he did have that
um
[Music]
so the thing about it too
he what he would do is for every
uh
show every episode
he would paint
three versions of the painting that you
saw him paint
uh the first one as i mentioned was done
prior to the taping uh and that was what
he would sit off camera so he could look
at it like it to refer to it while he
was painting
uh and then there was the second version
which is the one that he did live
essentially it was live on tape uh you
know that people actually saw him paint
and then after the episode was done
he would usually go back home
and he would paint a a real detailed
version of it
that would be included in the book like
he would paint it and then annette
kowalski would stand behind him and take
a whole bunch of pictures with her 35
millimeter camera
because at the end of every season
uh you know of the show
they would put out a book that had a
how-to
of every single painting that he had
done on every single episode
so he had to do every single painting
like three times you know what i mean
like once
just for a guide once live and once so
she could photograph
so they could do the how to so that's
how he would do it
um yeah so every single season they had
a book come out now the first season
that they did which was as i said just
this one show that they lucked into
um
you know they obviously nobody knew who
bob ross was yet so they didn't have a
publisher so the kowalski's to their
credit uh did cough up 30 000
to publish
uh the first season's bob ross like how
to book
so
yeah it was expensive to self-publish
your own books back then
now it doesn't cost anything uh other
than time
uh in case you gotta like hire somebody
else to do your [ __ ] but back then
yeah 30 grand and you had to like buy a
whole bunch of like [ __ ] copies and
then do it your goddamn self
i will also note that when you see him
do the episodes
he actually did between three and nine
episodes a day like what they would do
is that they they would do like a season
every quarter
so he's like so the first you know the
first week of the quarter
they would have bob come in like sunday
or monday and he would do
like three or four shows and then he
would do like three or four more shows
like the next day and they would just
keep doing and then like thursday they'd
have to like look through him and make
sure like and fix anything so he would
do like a lot of [ __ ] because like i
said he had to do a lot of paintings and
then he had to show up for the [ __ ] and
like talk and everything like that so it
was like a lot of work
uh he also told his kind of uh uniform
if you want to call it that uh of jeans
and his little just regular
solid colored collared shirt
um he wanted that so
i thought this was kind of funny he
wanted the show to retain a timeless
quality which i guess worked but the
afro kind of worked against that i will
say but again
if he didn't have the afro you wouldn't
recognize him so you know what i mean
another thing too was that
this was funny
he said
um
[Music]
like
like i said he he did like the whole
like talking softly and whispering and
stuff mainly because one it was mainly
female audience so he felt like
maybe people didn't want to get yelled
at because bill alexander was kind of
known for being like louder and like his
voice was harsher so he wanted to go
like in a more mellow kind of route
but he also said
i want to talk as though i'm just
talking to one particular person he's
like so when i do the show
um i'm addressing one person and that's
a person i'm really crazy about annette
kowalski phrased it as
he talked as though he's speaking to one
woman in bed
because he did say some like kind of
suggestive sounding stuff just caress it
just caress it you know what i mean it's
like because i've seen a couple
documentaries that kind of like um that
edited all that stuff together where he
was just like saying that kind of stuff
he's just playing around yeah he's just
like you do it like
[Laughter]
just take the end of your brush and just
kind of lick
it
do a little circle
a circle pressure
pressure over the spot just lick it
yeah it would be stuff like that
what he absolutely knew what he was
doing and he said and i and everybody
else knows what he's doing too
like you know i think that's why a lot
of people really liked the show yeah
because she felt like it was like you
know
there was that
little circles
little
high pressure
wet circles
rough but yet wet
[Laughter]
that sounds like some [ __ ] you would say
right of course
grantham said bob ross was a poonhound
who knew what to say to get women
viewers all hot and worked up yeah he
probably did i mean well most of them
were probably in their 60s or 70s but
they were on the [ __ ] other end of
the screen during the time he was
[ __ ] running probably
only old women watched out in the middle
of nowhere watching [ __ ] pbs or
little kids i watched it well yeah i was
a little kid yeah i was a little kid i
mean i wasn't a little little kid i was
probably like 12 yeah maybe
no maybe not even that old yeah i was
probably like 11 or 12 years old
uh which ross has laid more pipe tom or
bob yeah bob
probably
[Music]
[Laughter]
so yeah uh so obviously um this whole
this whole gestalt that he had working
um
absolutely was effective because
the show was a major success
and over the next couple of years uh you
know at first it was just kind of like
regional like i said like in the midwest
and after that like it just got picked
up by more and more pbs stations like
around the country and soon it was
national and became you know the most
famous you know the post most popular
like art instruction show on pbs let me
say something real quick what's that
grandpa's in there [ __ ] talk santa's
for y'all who don't know granthars and i
went to high school together he's ex-cop
by max soldier he goes very thin line
between cops and robbers both use
violence to accomplish their daily
missions both lived on the fringes of
the society both can manipulate people
only one gets a pension like granters
right another big thing the main thing
i've done a whole study on it i [ __ ]
read the psychology
the main thing is uh social class and iq
has a that's the main difference it's
the same personality type
just had you been born dumb and a lot
poorer you'd been a crook
but there are criminal masterminds out
there
uh just that they're not as common
anymore
they're usually during [ __ ] hard
times like italian gangsters in the u.s
they were high quality guys they
couldn't get jobs so they felt a crime
but
as soon as they could they got out of it
you know they don't their descendants
all own private businesses now
you know they didn't choose crime they
just didn't have a choice
a lot of times
okay that's always it tammy said what
happened all those paintings yeah uh
yeah bundy data says kowalski's yeah as
far as i know uh the kowalski's still
have all of them and they're just stored
away in boxes yeah that are numbered uh
i don't know why they're keeping all of
them
i don't know it it's very weird but you
know we'll get into that later because
uh
you know the smithsonian actually has a
couple of his [ __ ] and we'll get into
that
so uh by the end of the 1980s the joy of
painting his show which actually he
named they named it that because
you know uh
around that time it was just everything
was the joy of something the joy of sex
the joy of cooking the joy of blah blah
so that was like a big thing so that's
why they named that uh joy painting it
by the end of the 1980s had 80 million
worldwide viewers
and got 200 letters every goddamn day
now they also established an 800 number
where you could call the show and like
ask if you were having like problems
with your paintings and you can like
call up and like ask bob ross apparently
it's like hey my [ __ ] happy little
tree isn't all that happy and so he
would maybe like solve the problem for
you
so what they started to do was
essentially they started to like
franchise it out so
bob still you know he was doing the show
and i'm assuming he was still doing some
classes at this time but what they
decided to do was essentially like i
said franchise it so
they started doing training classes for
other
bob ross certified instructors you would
go i think it was a three week class
and you would go and you would learn the
aloprima method
and then you would be certified to go
around the country and teach your own so
they had like you know they had little
tendrils
uh all over the country where they had
different people teaching the same exact
method um and they were all like
certified bob ross instructors they had
all that going
uh so that's
they it's fun the funny thing is they
weren't just trained in the technique
apparently they were also trained to
have that like very soothing kind of
cadence and that very like there are no
you know there are no there's just uh
there are no mistakes or only happy
accidents and it's just like you know
what i mean so they're trained to be
like very
encouraging and very soothing and
and that kind of thing so i thought that
was kind of funny too
so as i said uh within a few years
um
much to bill alexander's chagrin bob
ross was way more famous
than him
now what ended up happening with this
even though obviously like i said the
two guys were friends because it was
like a whole mentor student relationship
um and the second season
of the joy of painting he dedicated to
bill alexander like the book
and
he was very open about bill alexander
being the guy that taught him the
aliprima method
and saying you know he taught me and now
i want to teach all of you
but the more popular he got and like i
said i kind of feel like bill alexander
got thinking like maybe
yeah it was fine when you were teaching
my classes but now you have a tv show
and then later when they thanks when
they um started doing their own like
line of paint and stuff like hey you're
stepping on my dick so he kind of got
like upset about it
but
yeah so he started getting more and more
popular and then bill like kind of had a
little bit of a flip out and they didn't
like really talk anymore
basically uh in 1991 bill alexander said
to the new york times
he betrayed me
i invented wet on wet which no he didn't
because like i said that has been going
around since [ __ ] 16th century
i trained him and he thinks he can do it
better
so
yeah he got a little uh a little cranky
about it like i said might not have just
been cause i think that's [ __ ] that
he said it's i invented wet on wet
because like i said no he didn't um
impressionists were doing that like
[ __ ] van gogh was doing that um you
know [ __ ]
velasquez was doing that like back in
the 16 1500s or whatever so shut up but
i will give him that bob ross
did
kind of they didn't sign anything but
they did kind of like have an
understanding that it's like hey i'll
teach your classes but i'm not going to
step on your dick as far as like
a tv show or having my own line of
paints and then they kind of did that
anyway like while bill alexander was
still on tv and like i said it's a
direct competition because it's the
exact same style
so
there was that so i can see why bill
alexander was mad because
yeah that was his student and the
student got more famous but you know he
kind of sounded like a bitter old man
too i don't know i don't know where i
fall on it um
i can see why he's mad but he probably
shouldn't have been bob ross was just i
don't even know if he was a better
painter necessarily but people just
related to him more i guess and that's
just kind of the way character has a lot
to do with success not so much quality
but that's what i'm saying like because
their paintings like looked very similar
to me like the the technique is very is
exactly the same um
but maybe like i said and bill alexander
was actually quite famous i remember him
being on tv and he was very successful
like selling his books and everything
like that but it's just bob ross came
along and
i guess everybody liked his chill
attitude better and that's just like i
said that's just in the medium how the
mop flops is
in the medium of society
character is what decides just look at
uh
um
uh what's that scientist that astronomer
we were talking about uh neil degrasse
kneel to crash neil degrasse tyson
delagrass tyson is not the best
astronomer he's the best communicator
for extra astronomers he's he he's he's
the guy you want on tv he's the one you
want representing astronomy and
astrophysics because he can communicate
his character
it's
that a community is a [ __ ] group all
right and most of those guys got their
[ __ ] noses buried in books and you
put them in the spotlight and they're
they
they're not the kind of guys that can
handle it you know what i mean [ __ ]
neil degrasse got [ __ ] he's got style
you know what i mean
he's alpha
he's going to represent
you know i like neil degrasse tyson i do
as well yeah and he was the great he was
a great successor to carl sagan sagan
was like that too
um
he's the kind of guy you wanted on
television
and that's why they had degrasse tyson
on [ __ ] cosmos when they were when
they brought cosmos back
that's the right guy for that
yeah because and i think we mentioned
this before it's not it doesn't always
go together that somebody is like [ __ ]
hot at science and also is like really
like charismatic and good on tv never
and also is like a good public speaker a
good communicator right usually those
two things don't don't usually go
together
so when it does that's like a real good
that's the yeah yeah that's that's a
real good thing right
those are the guys that you want
on television
representing their trade
yeah
so yeah so bob's show ended up running
from
january 1983 to may 1994
but reruns are still on
nowadays there's whole youtube channels
there's an official youtube channel and
the show is on all over the world they
know who the dude is in [ __ ]
japan
they know who the dude is in [ __ ] the
middle east
they've had the [ __ ] they had the
show all over the world which i kind of
blew my mind i was just kind of like i
thought it was more like an american
maybe a european thing i didn't realize
that like in [ __ ] middle east and
asia and [ __ ] like that that they have
this show over there but they absolutely
do so they know who that is he's got
they've got their own bob ross certified
instructors they people take classes and
[ __ ] like that and like learn that
method it's crazy
now so what ended up happening as i said
later on they decided to do hey let's do
what bill alexander does because he had
his own company selling art supplies
like he you know they would he was uh he
was with
i don't want to say it was weber it
might have been but um he had a paint
supply company and he would go in there
and like mix the paints the way he
wanted them and you know pick the
brushes that he wanted and how he wanted
them and then they would brand it with
his name so the kowalski's were like hey
we need to do that with bob ross so they
did
so they were able to promote this line
of art supplies and the class recordings
and [ __ ] like that into essentially like
at the time they were making like 15
million dollars a year which was a lot
like bob ross inc or bri as they call it
um
and then you know after bob died which
we'll get into in a minute like the
ownership of that pass completing the
kowalski's which was one of the main
things the netflix documentary was
looking into because obviously his
family is like super not happy about
that
um
yeah
now as i mentioned
bob estimated that he painted about 30
000 paintings during his lifetime
now uh
they don't really come up on the art
market because tammy was asking about
that um when they do the sale prices are
usually 10 grand and up
but uh they've never come up in any of
the major auction houses and bob ross
inc uh
doesn't
sell any of them i think the only ones
that get sold are ones that other people
had like
you know perhaps like from his early
days like he gave one to somebody else
or somebody that did a class with him
and took one or something like that um i
don't think they sell any of them the
kowalski's
now as i mentioned the only person
apparently at least according to the
netflix documentary that is authorized
to authenticate a genuine bob ross
painting is annette kowalski herself
and she's the one that runs the company
i think their daughter runs it now but
i don't know i'm assuming they're still
alive and as i mentioned earlier also in
the documentary that german guy that was
worked for the company and said oh i saw
like people just like signing his name
on [ __ ] and he thought that was kind of
[ __ ] up
now uh
so interestingly there's kind of a whole
thing i feel like when bob was on tv and
i kind of feel like thomas kincaid kind
of got this too and i've kind of made
fun of thomas kinkade because of this as
well
but
people that are quote-unquote real
artists or like art critics or whatever
we're kind of like [ __ ] on bob ross
a little bit it's like well it's not
real art it's just like
you know it's just like painting like
[ __ ] that is like hanging a hotel and
you're just not an artist and you're
teaching other people who aren't artists
and blah blah and they got like a little
bit snotty about it but as i said bob
ross never really seemed to care about
that
his whole thing was he just liked to
paint he thought it was relaxing and he
would say
like even on the show he would say stuff
like this is the only place where i can
be completely free like the world can be
like however i want it to be and so
that's kind of the message that he was
trying to get across and as i said he
was trying to get people
who thought that they couldn't create
anything or were afraid to create
anything he wanted to show them that
they could do it that it wasn't that
hard if you practiced if you really
wanted to do it you could do anything
you wanted and that was kind of like his
whole attitude he didn't give a [ __ ] if
it was like fine art or hung at a museum
or anything like that he was just wanted
to teach people and like just wanted
people to like see what they could do
and like see what they could come up
with
um honestly he was on uh i saw this clip
he was on the phil donahue show in 1994.
and phil says to him say out loud that
your work will never hang at a museum
and uh
bob ross said no well maybe it will but
it probably not the smithsonian and then
donahue asked him why and he said this
is art for anyone who's ever wanted to
put a dream on canvas it's not
traditional art it's not fine art and i
don't try to tell anybody it is so like
i said he wasn't real concerned about i
don't think he saw it as just like
assembly line necessarily he did seem to
enjoy it and he seemed to really like
doing it obviously
but he wasn't doing it
for maybe the same reasons that like an
artiste would be doing it
you know what i mean he just wanted to
be like i just wanted to paint like a
beautiful
scene that i saw in alaska and i just
thought it was beautiful so i painted it
and i want to show you how to paint it
so you can do it too and you can paint
however you want like even though you
thought you couldn't and that was really
all he seemed to worry about he didn't
really give a [ __ ] about
um you know if he was seen as like a
great artist or if he made a lot of
money at it or anything like that he
really really didn't seem to care about
that um
you know and like i said uh yeah i was
talking about the
beat the devil out do you remember how
he did that like how he would do the
[ __ ] the brush and he would like
smack it like that yeah get the paint
and
like i said he might have got that from
bill alexander although i don't remember
if bill alexander ever said beat the
devil out of it but he did say other
[ __ ] like that now one what i was gonna
say if you guys have never seen these
paintings they're good they're they're
real good it's mostly illusion though
he's using a knife
he's using a [ __ ] a paint knife
uh brushes uh he's using a bunch of
little tricks you even use toilet paper
to make [ __ ]
it's illusion but it i didn't see any
toilets yeah i thought he took a little
bit of toilet paper one time
and started patting it in the trees to
make the leaves
no he always sees brushes i don't know i
mean unless yeah i mean he did like 400
shows so he might have been but no he
always used he used brushes and a
palette knife that was it palette knife
hearing yeah his palate i thought he
used a
not really toilet paper but i thought it
was like a rolled up [ __ ] rag one
time
to make to make some leaves he might
have but he usually just used that like
round brush that stable brush that um he
just kind of like made and it happened
it happens fast it's like it's not fine
that's the method right yeah it's fast
fast it's kind of like taking a
photograph
but it's not accurate
not
it's accurate spiritually
that's what he said but i don't think he
was actually showing
he was making it up he was going along
he wasn't doing it uh he i don't think
he would take a picture of anything and
then paint what was in the picture was
he
no he would paint the he would paint the
landscape prior okay i don't know if he
was looking at anything when he painted
it initially so he had another painting
that he was looking at that he had
painted earlier okay like of a mountain
or whatever but he wasn't looking at a
photograph he was looking at a painting
that he had done earlier okay you know
what i'm saying yeah i i remember each
show was a little bit different he would
do some things different sometimes
one of the things one of my favorite
things that he did
um and i remember this episode and they
have clips of it online
he said um
that he had gotten a letter
from a guy who said
who was really sad and he was like
lamenting that it's like well i'll never
i'll never be able to learn to paint
like i know you say everybody can but
i'll never be able to learn to because
i'm colorblind and i just see everything
as like shades of gray
and so bob said i'll tell you what i'm
gonna do
i'm gonna paint a painting on this show
all in shades of gray just so i can show
you that it can be done yeah and he
[ __ ] did it he did a whole show it
was like this really like beautiful like
wintry kind of scene that was all like
blacks and grays and stuff like that and
i just thought that was so cool just to
show that guys like just because you
can't see colors right doesn't mean that
you can't do paintings you know what i
mean he's like look i did one without
any colors and it like turned out the
[ __ ] it turned out nice
but uh yeah
so there was that so
uh as i said most of the landscapes uh
were from alaska um
he was also real big into
this was kind of funny i saw this on the
documentary he was rolling into like
country music because of course he was
hopefully he was from florida yeah
and um 1987
he got to go to the grand ole opry uh
and hank snow was performing and they
said they got him up on stage and he was
like kind of shy to go up there they
said the audience went ape [ __ ] of
course they all knew who he was yeah
they said he said he couldn't believe it
well because they said everybody that
knew him said that he was like super
humble right you know what i mean like
and he was always real into
like anybody that came to him like he
would do [ __ ] like he got like a letter
from some old lady that said i'm driving
like an hour to see you it's like she's
old and she has a walker and she had
done a painting and she wanted to show
it to him and he waited in the [ __ ]
studio for until like 11 or 12 at night
until she got there
so she could come up and like give him a
hug and [ __ ] he said he was just like
just a nice man
and it's like he really really cared
about
people learning to paint and that was
like all he cared about he was just a
genuinely nice person which like i said
you don't really see that much like you
i don't know i kind of feel like most
people are like kind of not [ __ ] but
like just kind of more out for
themselves or they're not real genuine
like that but yeah but they said he
absolutely was they said he was exactly
like he was on the show and he was just
he was just very passionate about art he
was passionate about
you know uh about it because he kind of
felt like painting
sort of saved him in a way you know and
because he'd been in the military and he
liked it but he was like yeah it was a
you know i had to like shout at people
all the time i didn't really like that
and he's like and i didn't really like
all this negativity and like bad news
and all this kind of stuff he's like i
just wanted to be happy and i wanted to
make other people happy
and
yeah he was just kind of sick of it and
when he started painting he said it just
like opened up a whole new it's like it
not only
uh like chilled him out but he's like it
also made me look at nature like in a
different way like he noticed things
that he wouldn't notice before and it
made him like appreciate everything but
he died so young i'm older than him
already yeah which is crazy oh i mean he
we weirdly i mean he was a smoker
uh lifelong and he seemed to like have
uh he seemed pretty resigned to the fact
that he was probably gonna die like kind
of young
um not really sure why he thought that
maybe just because he smoked a lot i'm
not really sure
but
yeah so it's maybe i don't know
so
yeah so actually in those days guys the
guys in their 30s thought they were a
lot older than they really are oh it's
funny you know i'll run into people that
are in their 50s at the [ __ ] biker
bar and i look at him and go we're the
same age they look a lot they look a lot
older
and [ __ ] some of those people are
there
some of those like remember the girl
that died yeah she thought i was in my
30s yeah and she and she was making fun
of me oh you're sitting here saying
you're young you look younger than me
and that was weird a couple days later
she died
was just and how old did she say she was
she was uh 34. yikes
yeah
yeah well i showed you guys a video of
her i knew she was gonna die i'm famous
now at the biker bar because i told
everybody she was gonna die then she
died a couple days later
you did it yeah no
no i'm just teasing no [ __ ] um
i told her i said you gotta get her help
she's gonna die
we believe she said somebody's gonna
pick her up and kill her you gotta get
her out of because she was on those
drugs
somebody did pick her up and killed her
i was thinking serial killer no i was
dude on a motorcycle
he wrecked and it killed her he was on
the same [ __ ] she was on they were all
messed up i mean that's what i mean it's
like
particularly women like that are like
really really vulnerable yep you know to
[ __ ] like that and a dude who was just
like her sorry come on on the bike you
know i mean [ __ ]
they're riding from one bar to the next
and he was [ __ ] on meth
and they were doing meth and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and uh it killed her
he hit he ran off the road an accident
ran off the road [ __ ] hit some she
went flyer flying she was killed on it
killed instantly he's still alive
or last i heard he's alive he was in
critical condition
but i showed a video of her a couple
weeks back
yeah scary dead
i knew she was gonna die so i'm famous
over there now they know about the show
and everything nostra thomas yeah they
know they might be watching right now
we were talking about bob ross yeah and
this happy little treat yeah
they were like how did you know that was
going to happen i said it was obvious it
wasn't obvious to you they're like no
is i could tell she was gonna die
yeah yeah
uh but yeah so as i mentioned earlier
somebody mentioned earlier um
in the early 1990s only a few years from
when bob ross was going to die sadly
uh he actually got a little bit of a
resurgence because he did like some
spots for mtv because like i said it was
kind of like the whole gen x ironic
thing um i don't really know if he ever
really went away though i kind of feel
like i mean nowadays
shit's everywhere it feels like there's
like a lot of shows on now that are kind
of like referencing him people dress up
as him for halloween there's like
[ __ ] bob ross
products like all over the place like
everybody knows who he is and i feel
like a lot of that like especially like
the younger crowd that probably came
from that twitch thing like in 2015 but
even before that i feel like he never
really went away so i don't even know if
resurgence is the right word
now around 1995
one of the things that bob ross had
always wanted to do was do
a kids show about i think it was like
about just about nature like in general
and he did a pilot for it
and you can see like pieces of it online
still i think it was called elmer and
friends the adventures of elmer elmer
and friends
now apparently the kowalski said
absolutely not don't do it because he
had cancer at that point and they said
well you look sick
and they didn't want
anybody seeing him looking like that
um but he absolutely wanted to do it but
unfortunately he was only um strong
enough to do like the pilot episode you
can see it he doesn't look
bad uh he's wearing a wig
um
but because his hair had fallen out
obviously because of the cancer so he
had like an afro wig on because that was
like his trademark which like i said
okay but if you didn't know like you
probably wouldn't he doesn't look that
bad i didn't think but uh yeah you can
see it so the series did kind of go on i
guess or they did show it like after he
died but that was one thing that he
always wanted to do was like do a kids
show so at least he did get to do it
like a little bit
so again there's not a huge amount about
his personal life so like i said he was
married three times although that
doesn't sound as i know that sounds like
oh my god but um it's not as bad as it
sounds
um his first wife like i said i think
divorced him
uh
for various reasons i think steve who is
the guy that's on the netflix
documentary like his older son
um that was his mom
now his first wife is named vivian
and
uh apparently i guess
she divorced him i think because he
looks of infidelity and i think she
maybe died later um
now steve interestingly when he was
growing up he would be on the joy of
painting sometimes because he also knew
the method
and he would teach classes on his own he
was on the show and i kind of feel like
at least according to what steve said in
the documentary he's like you know i
always thought that my dad
wanted me to like take over the show
like after he was gone he's like but at
the time he was still like fairly young
and he's like you know i didn't really
want to do what my dad wanted me to do i
wanted to do my own thing even though he
was a good painter in his own right he
could paint just as good as his dad but
he's like i didn't really want to do
that
and i kind of feel like maybe he's sort
of sad about that now he's like we used
to argue about it a lot because bob was
like no i want you to like you know
after i'm gone i want you to like carry
on the the mantle or like carry on the
torch and steve didn't really want to do
it but now that he's like older he seems
like he kind of like regrets that a
little bit i could be putting words in
his mouth i'm not sure but that's kind
of like what it seemed like to me
um but he is a
an instructor and he's like i said every
bit as good a painter as his dad was
and so i don't know so that's kind of
sad
uh interestingly too like after his dad
died um he was mad at the kowalski's
for essentially like
having complete legal rights to
bob ross's name and image
so
steve was gonna try and strike out on
his own and do his own company like with
his own branded products and his own
classes
but
it didn't work out because of like legal
ramifications even though steve ross is
his name
illegally
um because the kowalski's have such a
stranglehold on bob ross on his name on
his image on the company
he doesn't really have any legal
recourse to do [ __ ]
at least under his own name if he did
he'd have to
call the company something else i would
guess and maybe he would have to like
distance himself from that because the
kowalski's are by all accounts very very
protective
of the bob ross brand
and even the dude's own son
apparently can't start his own company
with that name or that any relation to
it because
uh because of that
so yeah so
as i mentioned uh steve is actually
bob's first wife's son
and like i said they divorced because i
guess bob cheated on her allegedly i
don't really know uh and then she died
not too long after so then steve
and bob like bob essentially like was
left like a single father
and
then he married jane who's the second
wife and they were married a really long
time they didn't have any children
together but like i said they both
raised steve now bob seemed very very
devoted to jane and when
him and jane were running the company
with the kowalski's
jane was pretty much she did all the
administration administrative work for
the company like pretty much
um
weirdly
her and walt who was annette kowalski's
husband
would do all the administrative and
money [ __ ]
and bob and annette
would go out on the road and do all the
classes and do all the tour and shitlay
and do the show and everything
now
allegedly at least according to the
netflix documentary
bob and annette had an affair
um i don't know if that's true
but steve his son uh says that he heard
his parents arguing about it because
jane the wife
found out about it like
he said i heard her say have you had
relations with that woman and apparently
he admitted it
and
i guess she forgave him and they like
moved on from it because the two couples
were like working together all the time
but they were but it was like opposite
like each one was working with each
other's spouses
so
probably inevitable like that's a bad
[ __ ] happen but
i don't know if it's true but allegedly
allegedly according to the sun and
according to a couple other people too
like that knew them at the time um bob
and annette kowalski did have kind of a
thing going on like they had a little
bit of an affair so there's that
um however when bob's wife jane died in
1992 also of
cancer um
bob was like inconsolable and said so my
whole life went to hell in a handbasket
he said like after she died
two uh weeks two or three weeks after
she
died uh bob ross then got the uh
diagnosis that he also had lymphoma yeah
we smoking him damn cigarettes now i
think i'm not sure if this is entirely
true but some sources said that he had
had cancer before
and had gone through chemo and was in
remission so this might have been the
second time so maybe that's why like he
thought he was gonna die young because
it had already happened once i'm not
sure if that's true or not because like
wikipedia doesn't say that or anything
like that but a couple of other sources
that i saw in like one of the
documentaries said that he had had
lymphoma before
and had and was in remission but he got
he got the diagnosis again only a couple
weeks after his wife died that he had it
now he was kind of like i said he was
very private like about his personal
life he pretty much didn't tell anybody
that he was dying except for his very
very closest friends
interestingly night 1995 two months
before he died
he married his third wife as i said
linda brown
they think that he only married she was
a nurse that was taking care of him they
think that she that he only married her
for legal reasons because
he was afraid that after he died that
the kowalski's were going to take
complete possession of his name and the
company
and he wasn't going to have any recourse
or like because he wanted some of the
company to go to his
son steve apparently
and
he was afraid that they were going to
like steal his money now according to
the netflix documentary allegedly
um
[Music]
not too long before bob ross died i'm
talking about 85 pounds all his hair had
fallen out like bedridden
close to death
that the kowalski's allegedly kept
calling him
saying you need to sign this contract uh
pretty much signing the whole company
over to them we own your name we own
your image we own the company in totem
and we have all rights to it and your
son doesn't have any right to it and his
half brother who was the other guy that
was in on it jimmy um they don't have
any right to it and bob ross absolutely
would not
and his son said that he heard him
scream and he's like bob ross obviously
did not scream at anybody but he's like
i heard him scream at the phone you're
not taking my name
that's what he said i don't know if
that's true but that's what his son said
so he said he was really really pissed
that he felt like they were he's like
they're
harassing me on my deathbed like to get
me to sign this thing and bob ross
wouldn't sign it
so there was that whole thing but in the
end it ended up not mattering because
after bob died in 1995
um
the kowalski's did absolutely take over
there was a whole like legal wrangling
issue
but it turned out that the kowalski's
did absolutely have the rights over his
name his image everything like that so
they still
uh control all of the companies so
anytime you see anything
uh any kind of bob ross branded
merchandise any kind of like the joy of
painting books or
you know the youtube channel or anything
like that it has to go through them
and if you try to do some [ __ ] without
consulting them then they will
allegedly sue you they're apparently
like really sue happy as i said i don't
know if this is true i don't know if
they're as monstrous as the net i don't
know if it's monstrous but the netflix
documentary doesn't paint a real
flattering picture of them um and it
does say that they approach them like to
give their side of the story and they
wouldn't
uh so that the netflix documentary is
mostly coming from steve and like from
friends of theirs
friends of theirs said
that like really close friends of bob
ross said we didn't even know that bob
ross had died
until we read about it in newsweek
like they like the kowalski's didn't
even tell us
and because we wanted to go to the
funeral
and but we didn't find out about it
until later so it's like almost like
they were trying to like pretend he
wasn't dead because he was like their
cash cow and they didn't want anybody to
really know that he was gone so they
could just like keep running the company
as if he was still alive that was their
assessment of it
so i don't know if that's true but
that's how some of them felt and they
were really pissed that they
didn't find out from the kowalski's that
bob had died until later on but yeah he
died uh very very young
and uh so yeah he was really sad so yeah
he was only 52. he died july 4th 1995 in
orlando actually
and so it's interestingly one of his
friends uh
john pham i think is how you pronounce
his last name he said this on the
netflix documentary too
that
he wondered if maybe the paint thinner
that bob ross used all the time
had something to do with the cancer
which i guess is possible because the
way that he used i mean he used a lot of
paint thinner like the wet on wet
technique you have to use a lot of paint
thinner for that like to keep the paint
kind of supple
and you know he would like beat the
the paintbrush like against the [ __ ]
thing on the easel and so paint thinner
was going everywhere so it's probably
like going up your nose and stuff so i i
don't imagine that's good but i don't
know if that would have like caused the
cancer but it's possible so
so the weird thing about it is his grave
uh which is in which is here in florida
his gravestone says bob ross television
artist on it and it actually has his
like the logo
of bri like bob which is his face like a
kind of a stylized thing of his face
with the afro
and
i don't know i just thought that was
kind of weird that his grave has like
yeah it's a picture of him but it's
still like the logo of the company
i don't know maybe maybe that's what he
wanted i don't know but that's what's on
his gravestone and people still come to
the gravestone like all the time and
like leave their little paintings on it
and flowers and [ __ ] like that i don't
know it's just like it's [ __ ] sad but
yeah so
i yeah i would recommend
if you want to see like two sides of the
story it's really fascinating go on
youtube and watch bob ross the happy
painter that's kind of
like i want to say like the sanitized
like happy
clappy one
uh and the kowalski's are on that one
being interviewed
and so they don't say anything
controversial on there the netflix one
is more from it's mostly steve uh his
son
and other people that knew him oh and i
also want to talk about too like also on
the netflix documentary was
the jenkins who were like a couple of
artists and i remember they had a show
on pbs back in the day too they weren't
in direct competition with bob ross or
bill they didn't do landscapes they did
like uh still life like flowers and they
had like a different method so they had
their own thing going on they had their
own books they had their own contract
with weber that made their brushes and
paints and stuff
and they think
that particularly after but they didn't
have any issue with bob ross they
thought he was a great guy
but they said like after he died or when
he was getting sick and like the
kowalskis were had more control
allegedly um they think that
the kowalski's were trying to like
essentially like ruin their careers
because they looked they said once bob
ross
was you know kind of on the way out or
was on the decline like his health they
said annette kowalski
had her own show
where she started painting flowers
in the same method that the jenkins used
and she even put out a flower painting
book
that the jenkins said straight up like
ripped off a lot of the wording and the
diagrams and stuff like that from their
books
so they were pissed about that
and then they had had a contract with
weber art supplies for like a really
long time and they had a very specific
exclusive i think it was like a badger
hair like line of brushes
and they had those forever and they were
exclusive to them and they're like soon
after like the kowalski's had more
control allegedly um
there was a thing where weber called
them and said hey we can't do the badger
hair brushes for you anymore we're not
doing them anymore and they're like okay
whatever and then they found out that
the kowalski's had taken those badger
hair brushes and branded them as bob
ross brushes and were selling them
through weber so actually the jenkins
ended up losing their weber contract and
they ended up losing their tv show and
they think it was a direct result of the
kowalski's [ __ ] with them i don't
know if that's true or not but they're
still mad about it uh and they're on the
netflix show so that's actually and i
remember their show as well they were
also on and like i said it wasn't a
direct competition because they were
doing a different thing but they were
doing like more hobby type painting and
more still life type stuff but yeah
zach said uh thank you very much zach it
always seemed to me like bob's hairdo
would be a great place to hide things
he just said i wonder if he ever did
that at any of his 400 shows he just
like stuck the brush up there you know
he had to be like [ __ ] tempted
uh danny rolling ghost face hey we
haven't seen you in a while uh what do
bob ross paintings and female adult film
stars have in common they're both filled
with happy little accidents
yeah probably but yeah so
so yeah the
the happy clappy uh documentary is on
youtube called the happy painter
and then the more negative one is on
netflix and it's called bob ross
happy accidents betrayal and greed which
like i said it's kind of about the
kowalski so it's it's good to like watch
both of those and get like sort of a
both sides i don't know it's kind of
interesting the one that's on youtube
the happy painter one is from quite a
while back it's from 2011. so
it's more like laudatory about the whole
situation and much more like upbeat but
it's kind of interesting to see the two
and like contrast them so i watched
the negative one like last night and i
watched the positive one today so i
thought that was like kind of
interesting and like i said there's
another guy i can't remember what his
channel was but he did like an hour-long
uh thing about it today and i thought
that was but somebody said earlier that
the one about the the video on youtube
about the irish drunks like trying to
trying to paint a bob ross painting like
according to
the go-to that's like [ __ ] that
sounds really funny i'm gonna have to
like look that up and watch it because
that's probably like [ __ ] hilarious
but yeah so
i guess that's probably we probably got
to the end of it right you got to end it
look man it's time for us to make
something to eat i don't know about you
what are you going to make man i got
that i got that country gravy down there
with the sausage in it
maybe i'll just put that on some rice or
maybe make some biscuits
i don't
know i feel like eating biscuits
biscuits and gravy not really that seems
like
something seems like a little much
uh i'll come up with some i mean we had
like that big hunk of lasagna earlier
today and that's you had it i didn't
have that you didn't have lasagna nope
no no i forgot chinese leftovers oh okay
um
maybe uh it just seemed a little heavy
so i just like you know i mean i can
come up with all kinds of stuff
so rice and gravy would be easy to make
um
yeah i mean i guess that'd be easy
yeah we'll see we'll see
uh all right so i guess
all right so all right i guess we'll uh
wrap it up
this was a fun show i thought yeah i was
i was kind of thinking
you got a lot of people in there
watching it well yeah see i told you
okay uh danny rolling bro says tom break
out of the curly wig
that's too late see i took i knew he was
going to be no fun
i knew he was going to be really fun
i thought he was going to put a wig on
at some point but he never i don't have
that bob ross wig i mean i don't even
really have a curly one well you have
that curly like michael kane slash willy
wonka one yeah yeah i'd have to dig that
[ __ ] out i haven't been doing the wigs
lately yeah what's your what's the
matter i don't know man getting old
he's so funny getting old getting no fun
i'm [ __ ] hungry though because
couldn't shut it down
he's just gonna leave all right
all right hopefully you guys had fun i
had fun i thought this was like a really
interesting topic so thank you to the
people that suggested it because i
probably wouldn't have thought of it
otherwise but you know i grew up
watching this show so i thought it was
like really cool so hopefully you guys
thought it was cool as well so have a
good rest of your evening have a good
day tomorrow we will be back friday
night doing our uh fun friday night
sidetrack show where we'll drink some
more and talk about a bunch of [ __ ]
like we usually do so
other than that like have a good
rest of your evening and we'll see you
on friday night
bye